quickly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
the proceeding will start shortly
good afternoon and welcome to this
further evidence session of the joint
committee on the draft online safety
bill today we're pleased to welcome
francis haugen
to give evidence to the committee
francis we're delighted that you've been
able to make this trip to be in london
and give evidence to us in person and
also you know respect the personal
decision you've taken to speak out on
these matters with all the risks
incumbent with speaking out against a
multi-billion dollar corporation
i'd just like to ask you first off about
some of the
statistics facebook uses itself to
describe its performance in its
transparency reporting it says that it
removes 97 of hate speech that it finds
on the platform but the documents that
you've published suggest that it's ai
only actually finds two to three percent
of the hate speech that's there does
that mean that facebook's trans
transparency reports without any context
around those numbers are essentially
meaningless
i think it's important to um
there's a pattern of behavior on
facebook which is they are very good at
dancing with data that if you go and
read that transparency report on the
fraction that they're presenting is not
total hate speech caught divided by
total hate speech that exists which is
what you might imply expect given what
they said
the fraction that they are actually
presenting is the stuff that robots got
divided by stuff robots got plus what
humans reported and we took down
and it's true that 97 or something of
what they take down happens because of
their robots but that's not actually the
question we want answered the question
we want to answer is did you take the
hate speech down and that and the number
i've seen is like three to five percent
but i wouldn't be surprised if there was
some variation within the documents i
think it's a really important point as
essentially what we're looking at here
is the creation of an independent
regulator for the tech sector that not
only do we need answers but we need to
know what the right questions are as
well because the official statistics are
so misleading
and
part of why i came forward is
i know that i have a specific set of
expertise like i've worked at four
social networks i am an algorithmic
specialist so i worked on search quality
at google i ran ranking for
the new home feed on pinterest um i have
an understanding of how ai
can unintentionally behave facebook
never set out to prioritize polarizing
divisive content it just happened to be
a side effect of choices they did make
part of why i came forward is that i am
extremely extremely worried about the
condition of our societies
our condition of the goal itself and the
interaction of the choices facebook has
made and how it plays out more broadly
so things i'm specifically worried about
are engagement based ranking which
facebook has said before mark zuckerberg
put out a white paper in 2018 saying
engagement based ranking is dangerous
unless the ai can take out the bad
things and as you saw they're getting
three to five percent of things like
hate speech they're getting 0.8 percent
of violence in citing content
engagement based ranking prioritizes
that kind of extreme content
i'm deeply concerned about their under
investment in non-english languages and
how they mislead the public that they
are supporting them so facebook says
things like we support 50 languages when
in reality most those languages get a
tiny fraction of the safety systems that
english gets
also i don't think this is widely known
uk english is sufficiently different
that i would be
unsurprised if the safety systems that
they developed primarily for american
english were actually under enforcing in
the uk i wouldn't be unsurprised of that
and facebook should have to disclose
dialectical differences
i'm deeply concerned about the false
choices that facebook presents they
routinely try to reduce the discussion
to things like you can either have
transparency or privacy which do you
want to have or you can uh if you want
safety you have to have censorship when
in reality they have lots of non-content
based choices
that would sliver off a half percentage
point of growth a point percentage point
of growth and facebook is unwilling to
give up those slivers for our safety
and um
and i came forward now because now is
the most critical time to act
when we see something like an oil spill
that oil spill doesn't make it harder
for a society to regulate oil companies
but right now
the failures of facebook are making it
harder for us to regulate facebook
so on those failures looking at the way
the platform is moderated today
do you think it unless there is change
do you think it makes it more likely
that we will see events like the
insurrection in washington on the 6th of
january this year more violent acts that
have been driven by facebook systems do
you think it's more likely we'll see
more of those events as things stand
today i i have no doubt that the chat
like the events we're seeing around the
world things like myanmar and ethiopia
those are the opening chapters because
engagement based ranking does two things
one it prior prioritizes and amplifies
divisive polarizing extreme content and
two it concentrates it and so facebook
comes back and says only a tiny sliver
of content on our platform is hate or
only a tiny sliver is violence one they
can't detect it very well so i don't
know if i trust those numbers but two it
gets hyper concentrated in you know five
percent of the population and you only
need three percent of the population on
the streets to have a revolution and
that's dangerous i want to ask you a bit
about that hyper concentration
particularly an area that you worked on
in particular and that's facebook groups
i remember being told several years ago
by a facebook executive that the only
way you could drive content through the
platform is advertising i think we see
that is that is not true and groups are
increasingly used to shape that
experience
we talk a lot about the impact of
algorithmic-based recommendation tools
like news feed to what extent do you
think groups are shaping the experience
for many people on facebook groups play
a huge and critical role in driving the
experience on facebook uh when i worked
on civic misinformation this is like
based on recollection i don't have a
document but i believe it was something
like 60 of the content in the news feed
was from groups i think the thing that's
important for this group to know is that
facebook has been trying to extend
sessions like get you to consume longer
sessions more content and the only way
they can do that is by multiplying the
content that already exists on the
platform and the way they do that is
with things like groups and reshares so
if i put one post into a half million
person group that can go out to half a
million people and when combined with
engagement based ranking that group
might produce 500 a thousand pieces of
content a day but only three get
delivered
and if your algorithm is biased towards
extreme polarizing divisive content it's
like viral variants those giant groups
are producing lots and lots of pieces of
content and only the ones most likely to
spread are the ones that go out it was
reported i think last year by the wall
street journal that uh 60 percent of
people that joined facebook groups that
shared extremist content and promoted
extremist content did so act did so at
facebook's active recommendations so
this is clearly something facebook is
researching what action is facebook
taking about groups that share extremist
content
um
i don't know the exact actions that have
been taken in the last you know six
months a year um
actions regarding uh extremist groups
recommended actively to users promoted
to users is a thing that facebook
shouldn't be able to just say this is a
hard problem working on it they should
have to articulate here's our five point
plan and here's the data that would
allow you to hold us accountable because
facebook acting in a non-transparent
unaccountable way will just lead to more
tragedies do you think that five point
planning tests
uh i i don't know if they have a
five-point plan or any plan do they do i
don't i don't know i i didn't work on
that okay
but i mean to what extent should we be
considering groups or should a record a
regulator uk regulator be asking these
questions about facebook groups i mean
how significant what you're saying they
are a significant driver of engagement
and if engagement is part of the problem
the way facebook designed it then groups
must be a big part of that too groups
part of what is dangerous about groups
is that um you know we talk about
sometimes this idea of uh
is this an individual problem or is this
a societal problem
uh one of the things that happens in
aggregate is
the algorithms take people who have very
mainstream interests and they push them
towards extreme interests you can be
someone center left and you'll push to
radical left you can be center right
you'll be pushed to radical right you
can be looking for healthy recipes
you'll get pushed to anorexia content
there are examples in facebook's
research of all this
one of the things that happens with
groups and with networks of groups is
that people see echo chambers that
create social norms
so if i'm in a group that has lots of
covered misinformation and i see over
and over again that if someone gives a
covid vaccine
like things they encourage people to get
vaccinated they get completely pounced
upon they get torn apart i learn that
certain ideas are acceptable and
unacceptable when that context is around
hate now you see a normalization of hate
a normalization of dehumanizing others
and that's what leads to violent
incidents i mean many people would say
that
groups particularly large groups and
some of these groups have hundreds of
thousands of members in them yeah
millions they should be much easier for
the platform to moderate because people
are gathering in a common place
um i strongly recommend that above a
certain size group they should be
required to provide their own moderators
and moderate every post this would
naturally in a
content agnostic way
regulate the impact of those large
groups because if that group is actually
valuable enough they will have no
trouble recruiting volunteers but if
that group is just an amplification
point like we see um foreign information
operations using groups like this and
virality hacking that's the practice of
borrowing viral content from other
places to build a group
we see these these places as being um
if you want to launch an advertising
campaign with misinformation in it we at
least have a credit card to track you
back if you want to start a group and
invite a thousand people every day like
the limit is i think 2200 people you can
invite every day
you can build out that group and your
content will land in their news feed for
a month and if they engage with any of
it it'll be considered a follow and so
things like that make them very very
dangerous and they drive outsized impact
on the platform i mean what you say if a
if a bad actor or agency wanted to
influence what a group of people on
facebook would see you probably set up
facebook groups to do that more than you
would um facebook pages and run
advertising
and
that is definitely a strategy that's
currently used by information operations
another one that's used which i think is
quite dangerous is you can create a new
account and within five minutes go post
into a million person group right
there's no accountability there's no
trace
right uh
you can find a group to target any
interest you want to
very very fine grain even if you removed
micro targeting from ads people would
micro target via groups and
again i mean what you know
what do you think the company's strategy
is for dealing with this because again
there were there were changes made to
facebook groups i think in 2017 2018 um
to create more of a community experience
i think mark zuckerberg said which is
good for engagement but it would seem
similar to changes to the way news feed
works in terms of the content that it it
prefers and favors this is a these are
reforms the company have put in place
that have been good for engagement but
have been terrible for harm
i think there's a uh
we need to move away from having binary
choices there's a huge continuum of
options that exist uh coming in and
saying hey groups that are under a
thousand people are wonderful they
create community they create solidarity
they help with people with connections
if you get above a certain size maybe 10
000 people
like you need to start moderating that
group because that alone organ that
naturally rate limits it
and the thing that we need to think
about is where do we add selective
friction to these systems so that they
are safe in every language you don't
need the ais to find the bad content
is in your experience is facebook
testing its systems all the time does
facebook experiment with the way systems
work around how you can increase
engagement and obviously you know in
terms of content on the news feed we
know it experimented around the election
time around the sort of news that should
be favored so so how does facebook work
in
experimenting with its tools facebook is
continuously running many experiments in
parallel and little slices of of the
data that they have
i'm a strong proponent that facebook
should have to publish a feed of all the
experiments they're running they don't
have to tell us what the experiment is
just an id
and even just seeing the results data
would allow us to establish patterns of
behavior because the real thing we're
seeing here is facebook accepting little
tiny uh additions of harm
like when they weigh off how much harm
is worth how much growth for us
right now we can't benchmark and say oh
you're running all these experiments are
you acting in the public good but if we
had that data we could see patterns of
behavior and see whether or not trends
are occurring you worked on the civic
integrity team facebook so if you saw
something that was concerning you who
would you report to
this is a huge a huge weak spot um if i
drove a bus in the united states there
would be a phone number in my break room
that i could call i would say did you
see something that endangered public
safety call this number some some
someone will take you seriously and
listen to you in like the department of
transportation when i worked on counter
espionage i saw things where i was
concerned about national security and i
had no idea how to escalate those
because i didn't have faith in my chain
of command at that point like they had
dissolved civic integrity i didn't see
that there they would take that
seriously and we were told just to
accept under resourcing
but i mean
you would theory you would report to
your line manager
and would it be then up to them whether
they chose to escalate that
i flagged repeatedly when i worked on
civic integrity that i felt that
critical teams were understaffed and i
was told at facebook we accomplished uh
unimaginable things with far your far
far fewer resources than anyone would
think possible there is a culture that
lionizes kind of a startup ethic
that is in my opinion irresponsible
right the idea that you know the person
who can figure out how to move the
metric by cutting the most corners is
good
and the reality is it doesn't matter if
facebook is spending 14 billion dollars
in safety a year if they should be
spending 25 billion or 35 billion that's
the real question and right now there's
no there's no incentives internally
that if i if you make noise saying we
need more help like people will not you
will not get rallied around for help
because everyone is everyone is
underwater
in many organizations that ultimately
fail i think that sort of culture exists
there's no a culture where there's no
external audit and people with inside
the organization don't share problems
with the people at the top what do you
think people like mark zuckerberg
know about these things
i think it's important that all facts
are viewed through a lens of
interpretation
and there is a a pattern across a lot of
the people who run the company are
senior leaders which is this may be the
only job they've ever had right like
mark came in when he was 19 and he's
still a ceo there's a lot of other
people who are vps or directors who this
is the only job they've ever had
and so there is a lack of um
you know the people who have been
promoted were the people who you know
could focus on the goals they were given
and not necessarily the ones that asked
questions around public safety and i
think there's a real thing that people
are exposed to
and then they say look at all the good
we're doing like yes that's true but
like we didn't invent hate we didn't
invent ethnic violence and that's not
the question the question is what is
facebook doing to amplify or or expand
hate what is it doing to amplify or
expand ethnic violence you're right i
mean facebook didn't invent hate but do
you think it's making hate worse
unquestionably it's making it worse
thank you joining us remotely uh jim
knight
uh thank you very much joe and thank you
francis for coming and talking to us um
first of all just on some of that that
last fascinating discussion that you
were having
um
if you
you talked about if you were calling out
for help you wouldn't necessarily get
the resource would the same be true if
you're working in pr or legal within
facebook
um i have never worked in pr or
communications so i'm i'm not i'm not
sure um i do know that there is um i i
was i was shocked to hear recently that
facebook is rebrand is it wants to
double down on the metaverse and that
they're going to hire 10 000 engineers
in europe to work on the metaverse
because i was like wow do you know what
we could have done with safety if we had
10 000 more engineers it would have been
amazing um i think there is a view
inside the company that safety is a cost
a cost center it's not a growth center
which i think is very short-term in
thinking because facebook's own research
has shown that when people have worse
integrity experiences on the site they
are less likely to retain
i think regulation could actually be
good for facebook's long-term success
because it would force facebook back
into a place where it was more pleasant
to be on facebook
and that could be good for the long-term
growth of the company
thank you um
and then let me go back also to the
discussion about facebook groups
um by which we're essentially talking
about private groups clearly um
if you were asked to be the regulator of
a platform like facebook
how do you get the transparency about
what's going on in private groups given
that they're private
i think there's a real bar like we need
to have a conversation as a society
around how many people
well after a certain number of people
have seen something is it truly private
right is that number
10 000 is it 25 000 is it really private
at that point um because i i think
there's an argument that facebook will
make which is that you know there might
be a sensitive group which someone might
post into uh and we you know we wouldn't
want to share that even if 25 000 people
saw it which i think is actually um more
dangerous right that if people are
lulled into a sense of safety
that you know no one's going to see
their hate speech or no one's going to
see maybe a more sensitive thing like
maybe they haven't come out yet right um
that is dangerous because those spaces
are not safe right when a hundred
thousand people see something you don't
know who who
who saw it and what they might do so i'm
a big proponent of both google and
twitter are radically more transparent
than facebook right people every day
download the search results on google
and analyze them
and people publish papers
and because google knows this happens
they staff
software engineers who work on search
quality to write blog posts
twitter knows that 10 of all the public
tweets end up going out on their fire on
their firehose and people analyze those
and and do things like find information
operation networks
and because twitter knows someone is
watching they behave better i think in
the case of facebook and even with
private groups there should be some bar
above which we say enough people have
seen us it's not private and we should
have a firehose just like twitter
because if we want to catch national
security threats like information
operations we need to have not just the
people at facebook looking at we need to
have 10 000 researchers looking at it
and i think in addition to that we have
accountability on things like
algorithmic bias or understanding
whether or not our children are safe
that's really helpful and just on
twitter and algorithmic bias they
published some uh a report on friday
suggesting there was an uh there's a
an algorithmic bias politically do you
think that is unique to twitter or would
you say that that would also be the case
in facebook is that something implicit
in the way that these algorithms and
these platforms with all of their
algorithm algorithms are designed to
optimize clicks and therefore
there's something about certain types of
political content that makes it more
extreme that is endemic to all of these
social media companies
um i am not aware of any research that
demonstrates a political bias on
facebook um i am familiar with lots of
research that says the way
engagement-based ranking was designed so
facebook calls it meaningful social
interactions though meaningful could
have been hate speech or bullying up
until november 2020 it would still be
considered meaningful so let's call it
social social interaction ranking
i've seen lots of research that says
that kind of ranking engagement based
ranking prioritizes polarizing extreme
divisive content it doesn't matter if
you're on the left or on the right it
pushes you to the extremes and it fans
hate right anger and hate is the easiest
way to grow on facebook there's
something called virality hacking where
you figure out all the tricks on how to
optimize facebook and good actors good
publishers are already publishing all
the content they can they can do
but bad actors have an incentive to uh
play the algorithm and they they figure
out all the ways to optimize facebook
and so the current system is biased
towards bad actors and biased towards
people who pushed people to the extremes
thank you and
and then
currently we have a draft bill which
is uh is focusing on individual harm
rather than
societal harm
given the work that you've done around
democracy um
as part of your work at facebook do you
think that it is a mistake to emit
societal harm
i think it is a grave danger to
democracy and societies around the world
to omit societal harm
to give like a core part of why i came
forward was i looked at the consequences
of choices facebook was making and i
looked at things like the global south
and i believe situations like ethiopia
are just part of the opening chapters of
a novel that is going to be horrific to
read
right we have to care about societal
harm not just for the global south but
our own societies
because like i said before
when an oil spill happens it doesn't
make it harder for us to regulate oil
companies but right now facebook is
closing the door on us being able to act
like we have a slight window of time to
regain people control over ai
we have to take advantage of this moment
and my final question and thank you is
undoubtedly just because you're a
digital company you'll have looked at
user journeys and and uh
analyzed in a lot of detail the data
around how different user journeys work
is there any relationship between paid
for advertising and then moving into
some of these dangerous private groups
possibly then being moved into messaging
services into encrypted messaging um
are there user journeys like that that
we should also be concerned about
particularly given that paid for
advertising is currently excluded from
this bill
i am extremely concerned about paid for
advertising being excluded because
engagement based ranking impacts ads as
much as it impacts organic content i'll
give you an example
ads are priced partially based on the
likelihood that people like them reshare
them do other things to interact with
them click through on a link an ad that
gets more engagement is a cheaper ad we
have seen that over and over again in
facebook's research it is easier to
provoke people with anger than to
empathy or compassion and so we are
literally subsidizing hate on these
platforms it is cheaper substantially to
run an angry hateful divisive ad than it
is to run a compassionate empathetic ad
and i think there is a need for things
even discussing um disclosures of what
rates like people are paying for ads
having full transparency on the ad
stream
and
understanding um
you know what are those biases that come
and how ads are targeted
in terms of user journey journeys from
ads to extreme groups
i i don't have documents regarding that
but i can imagine it happening
beeben kidron
i thank you francis and thank you really
very much for being here and taking a
personal risk to be here we are grateful
um
i really wanted to ask a number of
questions that sort of speak to the fact
that this system is
entirely engineered for a particular
outcome and maybe you could start by
telling us what is facebook optimized
for
um
i think the thing that is not
necessarily obvious to us as consumers
of facebook is that facebook is actually
a two-sided marketplace it is about
producers in addition to being about
consumers like you can't consume content
on facebook without getting someone to
produce it
um facebook's switched over to
engagement based ranking they said the
reason we're doing this is we believe
it's important for people to interact
with each other we don't want people to
mindlessly scroll
but a large part of what was disclosed
in the documents was that they a large
factor that motivated this change was
that people were producing less content
people over facebook has run things
called producer side experiments where
they artificially give people more
distribution to see what is the impact
on your future behavior of getting more
likes more reachers
because they know if you get those
little hits of dopamine you're more
likely to produce more content
and so right now um you know facebook
has said repeatedly it's not in our
business interest to optimize for hate
it's not in our business interest to
uh like give people bad experiences but
it is in facebook's interest to make
sure the content production wheel keeps
turning because you won't look at ads if
your feed doesn't keep you on the site
and facebook has accepted the costs of
engagement based ranking because it
allows that wheel to keep turning
so that actually leads beautifully to my
next question which is i was really
struck not so much by
the harms because in a funny way they
just gave evidence to what a lot of
people have been saying for a long time
and a lot of people have been
experiencing
but what was super interesting was that
again and again the documents show that
the term
that facebook employees were saying oh
you could do this you could do that and
i think that a lot of people don't
understand what you could do so i'd
really love you to say to the committee
unpack a little bit
what were facebook employees saying we
could do about uh
providing the body image issues on
instagram what were they saying about
ethnic violence and what were they
saying about the democratic arms that
you were just referring to
i have been mischaracterized repeatedly
uh in certain parts of the internet that
i i'm here as like a plant to get more
censorship
one of the things that i saw over and
over again the docs was that there are
lots and lots of solutions that don't
involve picking good and bad ideas
they're about designing the platform for
safety
slowing the platform down
and that when you focus when you give
people more content from their family
and friends you get for free
less hateful divisive content
you get less misinformation you get
because the biggest part that's driving
this information is these hyper
distribution nodes these groups where it
goes out to 500 000 people
um some examples of non-content-based
interventions are things like let's
imagine alice post something and bob re
shares it and carol re-shares it and now
it lands in dan's news feed
if dan had to copy and paste that
continue to share it so his share button
was grayed out that's a two hop
researching
that has the same impact as the entire
third-party fact-checking system only
it's going to work in the global south
it doesn't require us to have a language
by language system it just slows the
platform down
moving into systems that are human
scaled instead of having ai tell us
where to focus
is the safest way to design social media
and i want to remind people we liked
social media before we had an
algorithmic feed
and facebook said like if you move to a
chronological feed you won't like it and
it's true with groups that are 500 000
people where just like a spraying
content people you're not going to like
it but facebook has choices that it
could do in different ways it could have
groups that were designed like these
things called discord servers
where it's all chronological but people
break out into different rooms as it
gets too crowded that's a human
intervention a human scale solution not
an ai driven solution
and so
slowing the platform down content
agnostic strategies human scale
solutions that's the direction we need
to go
why don't they do it oh man
so each one of these interventions you
know like so in case of reshares there
are some countries in the world where 35
of all the content in the news feed is a
reshare
and the reason why facebook doesn't
you know crack down on reshares or do
friction on them at least is because
they don't want to lose that growth you
know they don't want one percent shorter
sessions because that's also one percent
less revenue um and so facebook has been
unwilling to accept even little slivers
of profit um being sacrificed for safety
um and that's that's not acceptable
and i wanted to ask you in particular
about what a break glass measure is
uh if you would tell us
um
facebook's current security strategy
safety strategy
is that it knows engagement based
rankings dangerous but the ai is going
to pick out the bad things but sometimes
the heat in the country gets hotter and
hotter and hotter it might be a place
like myanmar that didn't have any
misinformation classifiers like labeling
systems no hate speech labeling
classified systems because their
language wasn't spoken by enough people
they allow the temperature in these
countries to get hotter and hotter and
hotter and when the pot starts boiling
over they're like oh no we need to break
the glass we need to slow the platform
down
and facebook has a strategy of only one
crisis has begun it slows the platform
down instead of watching as the
temperature gets hotter and and making
the platform safer as that happens so
that's what break glass measures are
okay so i guess why i'm asking these
questions is if you could slow it down
make the groups
smaller have break glass as a norm
rather than in emergency these are all
really safety by design strategies these
are all just saying you know make your
product fit for purpose can you just say
if you think that those could be
mandatory in the bill that we're looking
at
facebook right now has characterized the
reason why they turned off their break
the glass measures after the us 2020
election was because they don't believe
in censorship
these measures had nothing had largely
nothing to do with content there were
questions around how much do you amplify
live video do you give it a 600x
multiplier or a 60x multiplier little
little questions where facebook
optimized their settings for growth over
safety and i think there's a real thing
that we need to think about safety by
design first
and facebook draft to demonstrate that
they have assessed the risks they must
be mandated to assess the risks and what
like we need to
specify how good is that risk assessment
because facebook will give you a bad one
if they can
and we need to mandate that they have to
articulate solutions
because facebook is not articulating
what's the five-point plan to solve
these things
and i also want to raise uh the issue of
white listing because a lot of the bill
actually talks about terms and
conditions then being very clear and
then upholding terms and conditions and
having a regulatory
sort of relationship to upholding them
but what about whitelisting where some
people are not are exempt from terms and
conditions can you
give us your view on that so for those
who are not familiar with the reporting
by the wall street journal there is a
program called cross check so cross
check was a system where about 5 million
people around the world i think maybe
5.7 million were given special
privileges that allowed them to skip
skip the line if you will for um safety
systems right so the majority of safety
systems inside of facebook
didn't have enough staffing to actually
manually review
uh get so facebook claimed this is just
about a second check about making sure
the rules are applied correctly and
because facebook was unwilling to invest
enough people to do that second check
they just let people through
and so i think there's a real thing of
unless we have more avenues to
understand what's going on inside the
company
like for example imagine if facebook was
required to publish its research on a
one year lag
right they if they have tens of billions
of dollars of profit
they can afford to solve problems on a
one year lag right um
we should be able to know that systems
like this exist because no one knew
how bad the system was because facebook
lied to their own oversight board about
it
i think the last area i really wanna
think about is you know obviously all
the documents you bring come from
facebook but we can't really regulate
for this company in this moment we have
to look at the sector as a whole
and we have to look into the future and
i just wonder whether you have any
advice for that because we're not trying
to kill facebook we're trying to make
the digital world better and safer for
its users
engagement based ranking is a problem
across all sites right all sites are
going to be it's easier to provoke
humans to anger
engagement-based ranking figures out our
vulnerabilities and and panders to those
things
i think having mandatory risk
assessments
and
mandatory like remediation strategies we
need ways to hold these companies
accountable is critical because
companies are going to evolve they're
going to figure out how to sidestep
things
and we need to make sure that we have a
process that is flexible and can evolve
with the company's overtime
fantastic and and finally really just
you know do you think that the scope of
the bill it's user to user and search do
you think that's a wise move or should
we be looking for some systemic
solutions for the sector more broadly
used to use certain search um
that's a great question
and
i think any platform that has a reach of
more than a couple million people
the public has a right to understand how
that is impacting society because we're
entering an age where technology is
accelerating faster and faster
right democratic processes take time if
they're done well uh and we need to be
able
to think about how will we know
when the next danger is looming
because for example in my case uh
because facebook is a public company i
could file with the sec for
whistleblower protections if i had
worked at tick tock which is growing
very very fast that's a private company
and i wouldn't have had any avenue to be
a whistleblower
and so i think there is a real thing of
thinking about any tech company that has
a large societal impact we need to be
thinking about how do we get data out of
that company because
for example you can't take a college
class today
to understand the integrity systems
inside of facebook the only people
understand it are people inside of
facebook and so thinking systematically
about for large tech companies how do we
get the information that we need to make
good decisions is vital
thank you so much thanks jen thank you
um you mentioned the oversight board i
know you're going to be meeting with the
oversight board
they themselves don't have access to the
sort of information you've been
publishing all the information you've
been discussing
but do you think the oversight board
should insist on that transparency or or
disband itself
i always reject binary choices i'm i'm
not an arb person i love c d
um i think there is a great opportunity
for the oversight board to experiment
with the what are what is its bounds
you know this is an opera this is a
defining moment for the oversight board
what relationship does it want to have
with facebook
and um i think the i hope the oversight
board takes this moment to step up
and demand a relationship that has more
transparency because they should ask the
question why was facebook able to lie to
them in this way
what enabled that because if facebook
can come in there and just actively
mislead the oversight board which is
what they did
um i don't know
i i don't know what the purpose of the
oversight board is more of a hindsight
board than those
uh tim club and jones um francis hello
um
you've been very eloquent about the
impact of the algorithm um you talked
about uh
ranking pushing extreme content the
amplification
um
of
that sort of content uh an addiction
driver i think you've used the phrase
and this follows on really from talking
about the oversight board or a regulator
over here or indeed trying to construct
a safety by design regime what do we
need to know about the algorithm and and
and uh how do we get that basically um
should it be about the output of an
algorithm is a or should we be actually
inspecting the entrails for a for a code
um
uh
you know when we talk about transparency
it's very easy just to say oh we need to
be much more transparent about the
operation of these algorithms but what
does that really mean
i think it's always important to think
about facebook as a concert of
algorithms there are many different
algorithmic systems and they work in
different ways some are amplification
systems some are down regulation systems
and understanding how all those parts
work and how they work together is
important so i'll give you an example
facebook has said engagement-based
ranking is dangerous unless you have
this ai that's going to pick out the
extreme content
facebook has never published
which languages are supported
and which integrity systems are
supported in those languages
because of this they are actively
misleading the speakers of most large
languages in the world by saying we
support 50 languages
but when but most those countries have a
fraction of the safety systems that
english have
when we say
how does the algorithm work it's it we
need to be thinking about what is the
experience of the algorithm for lots of
individual populations
because the experience of facebook's
news feed algorithm in a place that
doesn't have integrity systems on is
very different than say the experience
in menlo park
um and so i think some of the things
that need to happen are
um there are ways of doing privacy
sensitive disclosures of um
we call it segmentation so uh imagine if
you divided the united states up into
600 communities
um based on what pages and groups people
interact with their interests um you
don't need to say this group is you know
35 to 40 year old white women who live
in the south you don't need to say that
you can have a number on that cluster
but understanding are some groups
disproportionately getting covenants
info
right now four percent of those segments
are getting eighty percent of all the
miss info
we don't we didn't know that until my
disclosure for hate speech is the same
way for violence incitement it's the
same way and so when we say do we
understand the algorithm we should
really be asking do we understand the
experiences of the algorithm and that if
facebook gives you aggregate data it
will likely hide how dangerous the
systems are because the experience of
the 95th percentile for every single
integrity harm is radically different or
the 99th percentile is even more
radically different than the median
experience
and i want to be really clear the people
who go and commit acts of violence those
are people who get hyper exposed to this
dangerous content and so we need to be
able to break out by those extreme
experiences
that's really interesting i mean do um
do you think that uh
that is practical for uh facebook to
produce would they need to um have
further research or have they got ready
access to that kind of information you
could produce that information today
right so the segmentation systems exist
like i that was one of the projects that
i founded when i was at facebook um that
segmentation has been used since for
different problem areas like coveted
misinformation and they already produce
many of these integrity
like statistics
so part of what's extremely important
about facebook shaft to publish which
integrity systems exist and in which
languages is right now like let's
imagine we're looking at um self-harm
content for teenagers
let's imagine we came and said we want
to understand how is self-harm
concentrated across these segments
facebook's most recent position
according to a governmental source we
talked to was they said we don't track
self-harm content we don't know who's
overexposed
if they were forced to publish what
integrity systems exist we could say
wait why don't you have a self-harm
classifier
you need to have one so we can answer
this question of is the self-harm
content focused on five percent of the
population because we can answer that
question if we have the debt
and we should wrap that into a risk
assessment that we require to be
delivered to us basically if i would if
i were writing
standards on risk assessments a
mandatory provision i would put in there
is you need to do segmented analysis
because the median experience on
facebook is a pretty good experience
the real danger is that 20 of the
population has a horrible experience or
an experience that is dangerous
is that the core of what we would need
by way of information from facebook or
other platforms or if there are other
information about data or i mean what
else do we need to be really effective
in in risk assessment
i think there's an opportunity imagine
if for each of those integrity systems
facebook had to show you a sampling of
content at different scores
right we would be able to come in there
so a problem that i'm really concerned
about is that facebook has trouble
differentiating for but in many
languages difference between
terrorism content and counter
counterterrorism content so think about
the role of counterterrorism content in
society it's how
people
make society safer
because facebook's ais don't work very
well
uh the for the language that it was in
question i believe it was um an arabic
island uh 76 of the counterterrorism
content was getting labeled as terrorism
if facebook had to disclose content at
different scores we could go and check
and say oh interesting this is where
your systems are weak and for which
languages because each language performs
differently
um i think there is a real importance
for um
if there were a fire hose for facebook
and facebook had to disclose what the
scoring parameters were
i guarantee you researchers would
develop techniques for understanding the
roles of those scores and amplifying
which kinds of content
um thank you very much indeed sharon
thank you so much for for joining us you
might be interested to know that you're
trending on twitter right now
so um so people are listening
i thought the i thought the most
chilling sentence that you've come out
with so far this afternoon i wrote it
down
anger and hate
is the easiest way to grow on facebook
i mean that's shocking
isn't it what a what a
horrendous insight
into contemporary society on social
media that that should be the case
one one report from facebook
demonstrates how there's different kinds
of feedback cycles that are all playing
in concert so it said when you look at
the hostility of a common thread so
let's look at a single publisher at a
time
and take all the content on facebook and
look at the average hostility of that
common thread
the more hostile the common thread the
more likely a click will go out to that
publisher
right anger incites traffic outwards
which means profit we also see that
people who want to grow really fast they
do that technique of harvesting viral
content from other groups and spreading
into their own pages into their groups
and they bias towards
stuff that gets an emotional reaction
and the easiest emotional reaction to
get is anger and psychology research has
shown this for decades
so those of us who are adults or
aspiring adults like members of the
committee will find that hard enough
to deal with but for children
this is particularly challenging isn't
it and i'd like to follow up on some of
baroness kidron's very good questions
specifically on harm
to children perhaps you could tell us
for people who don't know
what percentage of british teenagers can
trace for those who feel like this their
desire to kill themselves
back i can't even believe i'm saying
that sentence
but back to instagram
um i don't remember the exact statistic
i think it was around 12 percent it's
yeah it's it's 13 right
it's it's exactly that and and body
image is also made much worse isn't it
and why should that be for people who
don't understand that
why should it be that being on instagram
makes you feel bad about the way your
body looks uh facebook's own reports
say it is not just that instagram is
dangerous for teenagers
it is actually more dangerous than other
forms of social media because tick tock
is about doing fun activities with your
friends it's about performance
snapchat is about faces and like
augmented reality um reddit is at least
vaguely about ideas um but instagram is
about social comparison and about bodies
right it's about like people's
lifestyles and that's what ends up being
worse for kids there's also an effect
which is um
a number of things are different about a
life mediated by instagram than what
high school used to be like so when i
was in high school it didn't matter if
your experience at high school was
horrible most kids had good homes to go
home to
and they could at the end of the day
disconnect they would get a break for 16
hours
facebook facebook's own research says
now the bullying follows children home
it goes into their bedrooms the last
thing they see at night is someone being
cruel to them the first thing they see
in the morning is a hateful statement
and that is just so much worse
so they don't get a moment's piece they
don't get them on this piece you're
being bullied you're being bullied all
the time now you've already told the the
senate and you've also told us what
facebook could do
to make uh to address some of these
issues but some of your answers were
quite complicated
so um perhaps you could tell us in a
really simple way
that anybody can get
what facebook could do to address those
issues children who want to kill
themselves children who are being
bullied um children who are obsessed
with their body image in an unhealthy
way and all the other issues that you've
addressed but what is it that facebook
can do now
without difficulty
to solve those issues
there are a number of interplay
factors that interplay that drive those
issues on a most basic level children
don't have as good self-regulation as
adults do that's why they're not allowed
to buy
cigarettes when kids describe their
usage of instagram
they have facebook's own research
describes it as an addict's narrative
as an addict's narrative the kids say
this makes me unhappy i feel like i
don't have the ability to control my
usage of it and and i feel if i left i'd
be ostracized um i i am deeply worried
that it may not be possible to make
instagram safe for a 14 year old and i i
sincerely doubt it's possible to make it
safe for a 10 year old so they shouldn't
be on it
i i i
i would be surprised i would love to see
a proposal from an established
independent agency that had a picture of
what a safe version of instagram for a
14 year old you don't think such a thing
exists i am not aware of something does
does facebook care whether or not
instagram is safe for a ten-year-old uh
what i
what i find very deeply misleading about
facebook's statements regarding children
is they say things like we need
instagram kids because kids are gonna
lie about their age and so we might as
well have a safe a safe thing for them
um
facebook should have to publish what
they do to detect 13 year olds on the
platform because i guarantee you what
they're doing today is not enough
and facebook's own research does
something where um
facebook can guess how old you are with
a great deal of precision because they
can look at who your friends are who you
interact with because you're at school
yeah because that's a bit of a giveaway
if you're wearing a school uniform
chances are you're on 20. but i wanted i
want to disclose a very specific thing
this is something actually the senate
found when we disclosed the documents to
them they found that facebook had
estimated the ages of teenagers and
worked backwards to figure out how many
kids lied about their ages and how many
were on the platform and they found for
some cohorts 10 to 15
10 to 15 of 10 year olds were on the
platform facebook should have to publish
those stats every year so we can grade
how good were they at keeping kids off
the platform
right so
facebook can resolve this solve this if
it wants to do so
basically can make a huge dent on this
if they wanted to and they don't because
they know that young users are the
future of the platform and the earlier
they get them the more likely they'll
get them hooked okay and and obviously
young users are no different from the
rest of us they're also getting to see
all the disinformation about covet and
everything else that the rest of us are
getting to see and just remind us what
percentage of disinformation is being
taken down by facebook
i actually don't know that staff top my
head well i believe it's i i from from
what i understand it's three to five
percent oh that's for hate speech yeah
but i'm sure it's approximately the same
well i guess so it's probably um even
less from the perspective of
the only information that is false at
facebook is information that has been
verified by a third party fact
fact-checking system
and that can only catch viral
misinformation so that's misinformation
that goes to half a million a million
people and this is the most important
thing for the uk i don't believe there's
any anywhere near as much third party
fact checking coverage for the uk
compared to the united states
and and the wonders of texting uh tell
me that actually the figure is 10 to 20
for this information yes so i stand
corrected 10 to 20 for disinformation
and three to five percent for hate
speech so a vast amount of
disinformation and hate speech is
getting through to to children
which must present children with a very
peculiar gender sense of the world
and we have absolutely no idea do we
how those children are going to grow up
and
change and develop and mature having
lived in this very poisonous
society at this very delicate stage
in their development
i'm extremely worried about the
developmental impacts of instagram on
children beyond the fact that if you get
an eating disorder when you're 16 you
may have osteoporosis for the rest of
your life right they're going to be
women who are walking around this earth
in 60 years with brittle bones because
of choices facebook made now but i think
the secondary thing that i'm super
scared about is kids are learning that
people they care about treat them
cruelly because kids on instagram when
they're when they were moved with the
feedback of watching someone cry or
watching someone wins
they they're much more hateful they're
much meaner to people even who are their
friends imagine what the domestic
relationships will be like for those
kids when they're 30 if they learn that
people who care about them are mean to
them
it's a very disturbing thought and the
other very disturbing thing that you've
told us about which i think most people
haven't focused on is the idea
that uh
language
matters so we think facebook is bad now
but what we don't tend to realize in our
very anglo-centric culture is that all
the other languages around the world are
getting no moderation of any kind at all
i think the thing that should scare you
even more living in the uk is the uk is
a diverse society those languages aren't
happening abstractly in africa and
getting the raw dangerous version of
facebook a version of facebook the
marcus said himself is dangerous
engagement based ranking is dangerous
without ai that's what market zuckerberg
said those people are also living in the
uk and being fed misinformation
that is dangerous that radicalizes
people and so language based coverage is
not just a good for individuals thing it
is a national security issue
that's interesting
on the social front you pointed out that
uh there might be differences between
the united kingdom and the united states
which it's not picking up and i've said
this to the committee before but i've
got personal experience of this in
twitter where i was
a gay man i was called a greasy bender
on uh on on twitter and i reported it to
twitter twitter wrote back and told me
that there was nothing wrong with being
called the greasy bender
and then i wrote back giving the exact
a chapter and verse from their community
standards which showed it was
unacceptable and
somebody wrote back to me presumably
from california telling me that it was
absolutely acceptable now to be generous
it may just be that they didn't know
what a bender
was because it's it's not in use in the
united states but honestly i think i'd
have googled if if i'd been them just to
to find out why this mp was being so
persistent about this particular
particular word um
in in a in a nutshell what do you want
us to do in this game what's the most
useful thing in addressing
the concerns that you've
raised here i think forcing facebook so
i want to be clear bad actors have
already tested facebook they've done
they've gone and
tried to hit the rate limits they've
tried experiments with content they know
facebook's limitations the only one who
doesn't know facebook's limitation are
good actors
facebook needs to disclose what its
integrity systems are and which
languages they work in and the
performance per language or per dialect
because i guarantee you the safety
systems that are designed for english
probably don't work as well on uk
english versus american english all of
this makes facebook sound
relatively benign doesn't it as if it's
just not doing quite what it should be
doing but what your
evidence has shown to us is that
facebook is
is failing to prevent harm to children
it's failing to prevent the spread of
disinformation it's failing to present
hate speak it does have the power
to deal with these issues it's just
choosing not to
which makes me wonder whether facebook
is just
fundamentally evil is is facebook evil i
cannot see into the hearts of men and i
i think there is a real thing of um
people
good people and facebook is
overwhelmingly full of conscientious
kind empathetic people you have to like
people good people who are embedded in
systems with bad incentives are led to
bad actions
and there is a real pattern of people
who are willing to look the other way
are promoted more than people who raise
alarms we know where that leads in
history
don't we so could we compromise that
it's not evil maybe that's an overly
moralistic word um but but the way that
some of the outcomes of facebook's
behavior
is evil i think it's negligent
malevolent
uh malevolent implies intent and i
cannot see into the hearts of men but i
do believe there is a pattern of
inadequacy that facebook is unwilling to
acknowledge its own power
it believes in a world of flatness which
hides the difference like children are
not adults right
they they believe in flatness and they
won't accept the consequences of their
actions and so i think that is
negligence and it is um
uh in uh ignorance but i i i can i can't
see i can't see it into their hearts and
so i don't want to consider him a loved
one well i respect your
um your desire obviously to answer the
question in your own way but given the
evidence that you've given us
i i think a reasonable person running
facebook seeing the consequences of the
company's behavior
would i imagine have to conclude
that what they were doing the way their
company was performing and the outcomes
were malevolent and would want to do
something about it i would certainly
hope so
back to you too
thank you very much
just on that point about would you mind
if i rest in my voice for five minutes
just could we take a break for a second
or
or we
i'm sorry i
i i don't know how long we're going to
go so if we go for two and a half hours
i'll i'll never mind we ask your friends
okay thank you
on that point about intent um i mean
someone might have intended to to do a
bad thing but if their actions are
causing that and they're told about it
and they don't change their strategy
then what do you say about them then
i am a big proponent of we need to look
at systems and how systems perform and
this idea that and actually this is this
is a huge problem inside of facebook
facebook has this philosophy
that they can if they establish the
right metrics they can allow people free
reign right they like i said they're
they're intoxicated by flatness they
have the largest open floor plan office
in the world it's a quarter of a mile
long in one room right they believe in
flatness they believe that if you pick a
metric you can let people do whatever
they want to move that metric and that's
all you have to do if you had better
metrics you could do better actions but
that ignores that if you learn data that
that metric is leading to harm which is
what meaningful social interactions did
that the metric can get embedded because
now there are thousands of people who
are all trying to move a metric and
people get scared to change a metric and
and you know make people not get their
bonuses
and so i think there is a real thing of
there is no will at the top you know
mark zuckerberg is has unilateral
control over three billion people right
there's no will at the top to make sure
these systems are run in an adequately
safe way
and i think until we bring in a
counterweight things will be operated
for the shareholders interest and not
for the public interest
thank you um joining us dean russell
thank you chair and uh thank you again
um for joining us today it's it's
incredibly important and your testimony
has been heard loud and clear um the
points i want to just pick up on was
about addiction
if facebook were
optimizing algorithms
um
in the same way or viewed to be doing it
in the same way as a drug company was
trying to improve the diction of their
product um it would probably be viewed
very differently and i just wondered if
you could explore a bit further this
role of addiction and whether actually
facebook is doing something that we
perhaps have never seen in history
before which is creating an addictive
product that perhaps isn't consumed but
actually
through taking the drug as it were but
is consumed virus screen
on facebook inside of facebook there are
many euphemisms that are meant to hide
the emotional impact of things so for
example the ethnic violence team is
called the social cohesion team because
ethnic violence is what happens when
social cohesion breaks down for
addiction the metaphor is problematic
use people are not addicted they have
problematic use um the reality is that
using large-scale studies so these are a
hundred thousand people
facebook has found that problematic use
is much worse in young people than
people who are older
so the bar for problematic use is that
you have to be self-aware enough and
honest enough with yourself to admit
that you don't have control over your
usage and that is harming your physical
health your your school or your
employment
and for uh 14 year olds it peaks you
know their first year they haven't
gotten quite enough problematic use yet
but for by the time you get to be 14
between 5.8 and 8 of kids say they have
problematic use and that's a huge
problem
if that many 14 year olds are that
self-aware and that honest the real
number is probably you know 15 20
um i am deeply concerned about
facebook's role in um hurting the most
vulnerable among us
facebook has studied who has been most
exposed to misinformation and it is
people who have been recently widowed
people who are recently divorced people
who move to a new city people who are
socially isolated and i am deeply
concerned that they have made a product
that
can lead people away from their real
communities and isolate them in these
rabbit holes and these filter bubbles
because what you find is that when
people are sent targeted misinformation
to a community it can make it hard to
reintegrate into larger society because
now you don't have shared facts
so that's the real harm i like to talk
about the idea of the misinformation
burden instead of thinking of it as
because like it is a burden when we
encounter this kind of information
facebook right now um
doesn't have any disincentive
for trying to do high quality shorter
sessions imagine if there was a syntax
that was a penny an hour right this is
like dollars a year for facebook per
user
imagine if there was a syntax that
pushed facebook to have shorter shorter
sessions that were higher quality
nothing today is is incentivizing them
to do this all the incentives say if you
can get them to stay on the platform
longer you'll get more ad revenue you'll
make more money
and and so with that and thank you
that's very helpful but in terms of the
way that often the discussion is around
the bill especially that we're looking
at the online safety bill
is around
the comparison being with it being a
publisher or publishing platform
but should we be looking at this much
more about almost a product approach
which in in essence is causing addiction
as you say with young people and as you
mentioned earlier about the impact on
you know trying to get a greater high
almost through the dopamine in their
brain so we've heard previous testimony
from experts highlighting that actually
children's brains seem to be changing
because they're using uh
facebook and other platforms uh to a
large extent over many many hours and if
they were being given a white powder and
they were having the same symptoms the
same outputs we'd be very quick to clamp
down on that but because it's viral
screen and we call it facebook and we
think everyone's using it nicely that
that doesn't happen so it should be
interested in your view on on the impact
on children whether facebook have
actually been looking at that but also
whether we should be doing this
almost in with regards facebook being a
product rather than a platform i find it
really telling that if you go to silicon
valley and you look at the most elite
private schools they often have zero
social media policies that they try to
establish cultures where like you don't
use phones and you don't connect with
each other on social media the fact that
that is
a trend in you know
private schools in silicon valley i
think should be a warning to us all
um
it is super scary to me that we are not
taking like a safety first perspective
with regard to children right like
safety by design is so essential with
kids because the burden that we've we've
uh we've set up up until now is the idea
that the public has to prove to facebook
that facebook is dangerous
facebook has never had to prove that
their product is safe for children
right and we need to flip that script
like with with pharmaceuticals a long
time ago we said it's not the obligation
of the public to say this medicine is
dangerous it's the obligation of the
producer to say this medicine is safe
you know we've done this over and over
again and this is the right moment to
act this is the moment to change that
relationship with the public
and if i may just on that point um sorry
my uh my screen seems to be uh switching
off my apologies um uh with regards to
that point um of of addiction um
have there been any studies from your
awareness within facebook and within the
documents you've seen where they have
actually looked at how they can increase
addiction via the algorithms
i have not seen any documents that are
as explicit as saying on
facebook is trying to make addiction
worse but i have seen documents where on
one side someone's saying the number of
sessions per day that someone has like
the number of times they visit facebook
is indicative of their risk of
exhibiting problematic use
but on the other side they're clearly
not talking to each other someone says
interesting
an indicator that people will still be
on the platform in three months is if
they have more sessions every day we
should figure out how to drive more
sessions
and this is an example of facebook is
not because their management style is
flat
there isn't enough cross promotion
there's not enough cross filtration and
the side that is responsible for growing
the company is often hit is kept away
from the side
highlights harms
and that kind of world where it's not
integrated that causes dangers and it
makes the problem worse
thank you
i'm sorry dave we pause it it's um 25 to
2 i'm going for over an hour so i think
we'll take a 10 minute break at this
point thank you so much
currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
thank you the evidence session will now
resume and i'd like to ask dean russell
to continue with these questions
thank you chair and
thank you again for your responses
earlier the um the question i just want
to build upon i've got a
few more questions but hopefully won't
take too long um one just continues on
the addictivity if there's such a word
for uh for facebook and similar
platforms
do you
you mentioned before that you haven't
seen any specific research in that area
but i just wondered if there's any
awareness within facebook of the actual
effect
of
lo
of long use of facebook and similar
platforms on children's brains as
they're developing
i think there's an important question to
be asked which is what is the
incremental value added to a child after
some number of hours of usage per day
i'm not a child psychologist i'm not a
neurologist i can't advise on what that
time limit should be but i think we
should ask like we should weigh a
trade-off which is you know i think it's
possible to say that there
there is value that is given from
instagram but i think there's a real
question of is the first hour how
valuable is the second hour after the
first hour how value is the third hour
after the second hour because
the impacts are probably more than
cumulative right they probably expand
substantially more over time and so i
think that those are great questions to
ask i don't have a good answer for you
thank you just very finely on that point
before i move on to just a a small extra
point do you think from your experience
that the senior leadership including
mark zuckerberg at facebook actually
care if they're doing harm to the next
generation of
society especially children
um i cannot see into the hearts of men
and so i i don't know i don't know what
their position is i know that there is a
philosophy inside the company that i
have seen repeated over and over again
which is that people focus on the good
right there is a culture of positivity
um and and you know that's not always a
bad thing but the the problem is that
when it's so intense
that it discourages people from looking
at hard questions then it becomes
dangerous
and i i think it's really
you know we haven't adequately invested
in security and safety and they have
consistently when they see a conflict of
interest between
uh profits and people they keep choosing
profits
so you'd agree that actually it's a sign
that they perhaps don't care by the fact
they haven't investigated or even done
research into this area i think they
need to do more research and i think
they need to take more action and they
need to accept that it's not free that
it that safety is important and is a
common good and that they need to invest
more in it
thank you and if i may just um just on a
slightly different point if i may
you're obviously now a globally known
whistleblower and one of the
aspects that we've looked at over the
past few weeks is around anonymity and
one of the regular points that's made is
that if we pushed on anonymity within
this bill that that would do harm to
people who want to be whistleblowers in
the future i just want to get your sense
of whether you agree with that and if
you have any particular view on
anonymity
um
i worked on google plus in the early
days i was actually the person in charge
of profiles on google plus when google
internally had a small crisis over
whether or not real names should be
mandated and there was a movement inside
the company called real names considered
harmful
and it detailed at great length all the
different populations that are harmed by
um like excluding anonymity and that's
groups like domestic abuse survivors who
you know their their personal safety may
be at risk if they're forced to engage
with their real names um
anonymity i i think it's important to
weigh what is the incremental value of
requiring real names um real names uh
are difficult to implement so most
countries in the world do not have
digital services where we could verify
like someone's id versus like their
picture or like a database
and in a world where someone can use a
vpn and claim they're in one of those
countries and register a profile
that means they could still do whatever
action you're afraid of them doing today
the second thing is that facebook knows
so much about you
and if they're not giving you
information to facilitate investigations
that's a different question
facebook knows a huge amount about you
today like the idea that you're
anonymous on facebook is is is i think
not actually accurate for what's what's
happening and we still see these harms
but the third thing is the real problem
here is the systems of amplification
like this is not a problem about
individuals it's about
having a system that prioritizes and
mass distributes divisive polarizing
extreme content
and that in situations where you just
limit content or not limit when you just
show more content from your family and
friends you get for free
safer less dangerous content and i think
that's the greater solution
and so very finally just in terms of
anonymity for this report then are you
saying that we we should be focusing
more on the proliferation of content to
large numbers than we should on
anonymity of the the source of the
content yes i think the the the much
more scalable effective solution
is thinking about how is content
distributed on these platforms what is
what are the biases of the algorithms
what are they distributing more of and
concentration like are certain people
being pounded with this bad content for
example um
you know this happens on both sides it's
both people being hyper exposed to
toxicity and hyper exposed to abuse
right
thank you i'll pass back over to the
chair next time i've got colleagues who
wanted to come in thank you very much um
thank you i just wanted to just ask you
about the point you just made on
anonymity and what you're saying it
sounds like anonymity currently exists
to hide the identity of the abuser from
their victim but not the identity of the
abuser to the platform
platforms have
far more information about accounts than
i think people are aware of
and
platforms could be uh more helpful in
identifying
those connections in cases of crimes um
and so i think it's a question of
facebook's willingness to act to protect
people
more so than a question of
those people anonymous on facebook the
reason i think particularly pertinent
point here having this debate on
anonymity is that one of the concerns is
that if you say well
the platform should always know who the
account user is so if there was a
request from law enforcement that they
could comply with it and some people say
well if we do that there's a danger of
their systems being hacked all that
information being got got out in another
way but from what you're saying is
practically
the company already has that data and
information anyway it knows so much
about each one of its users regardless
of the set settings for an account and
obviously on facebook you have to have a
your name for the account anyway in
theory um that that
i think what you're saying is in
practical terms and limiting doesn't
really exist because the companies know
so much about you
you can imagine designing facebook in a
way where as you used the platform more
you got more reach right you know like
the idea that reach is earned is not a
right
um
in that world as you interact with the
platform more the platform will learn
more and more about you the fact that
today you can make a throwaway account
and take an action
um like that opens up all sorts of doors
but i just want to be clear in a world
where you require people's like ids
you're still going to have that problem
because facebook will never be able to
mandate that for the whole world because
lots of countries don't have those
systems and as long as you can pretend
to be in that country and register
account you're still going to see all
those harms
thank you
um if i could join other colleagues and
thank you so much for being here today
because this is so important to us
um
the bill
as it stands exempts
legitimate news publishers
and the content that comes from
registered news publishers
from its scope um but there is no
obligation on facebook and indeed the
other platforms uh to carry that
journalism
instead it'll be up to them
uh to apply
the codes which are laid down by the
regulator
directed by government
in the form of the
secretary of state
ostensibly to make their own judgments
about whether or not to carry it now
it's going to be ai which is doing that
is going to be the black box which is uh
doing that
which leads to the possibility in effect
of censorship
by algorithm
and
what i'd really like to know is in your
experience do you trust
ai to make those sorts of judgments or
will we get to the sort of situation
where
all news legitimate news about terrorism
is in fact the effect censored out
because the black box can't
differentiate between news about
terrorism and content which
is promoting terrorism
um i think there's a couple of different
issues there to unpack so the first
question is around exempting um you know
uh establish
excluding journalism
right now my understanding of how the
bill is written is that a blogger could
be treated the same as an established
outlet that has editorial standards
people have shown over and over again
that they want high quality news people
willing to pay for high quality news now
at rates that are it's actually
interesting one of the highest rates of
subscription news is amongst like 18
year olds right young people understand
the value of high quality news when we
treat a random blogger and an
established
high quality news source the same
we actually dilute the access of people
to high quality news that's the first
issue um i'm very concerned that if you
uh just exempt it across the board
you're gonna make the the regulations
ineffective the second question is
around can ai identify um safe versus
dangerous content and part of why we
need to be forcing facebook to publish
which integrity systems exist in which
languages and performance data is right
now those systems don't work that like
facebook's own documents say they have
trouble differentiating between new uh
content promoting terrorism and
counter-terrorism speech
at a huge rate you know the number i saw
was 76 of counter-terrorism speech in
this this at-risk country
was getting flagged as terrorism and
taken down and so any system where the
solution is ai is a system that's going
to fail
instead we need to focus on slowing the
platform down making a human scale and
letting humans choose what we focus on
not letting an ai which is going to be
misleading us make that decision
so what practically could we do in this
bill
deal with that problem
great question i think mandatory risk
assessments with um standards like how
good does this risk assessment need to
be
analysis around things like segmentation
like understanding are some people
hyperexposed all those things are
critical and i think the most important
part is
having um
having a process where it's not just
facebook articulating harms it's also
the regulator going out and collecting
harms from other populations and then
turning back to facebook and saying you
need to articulate how you're going to
solve these problems
because right now the incentives for
facebook are aligned with their
shareholders and the point of regulation
is to pull that center of mass back
towards the public good
and right now facebook doesn't have to
solve these problems it doesn't have to
disclose they exist and it doesn't need
it doesn't have to come up with
solutions but in a world where they were
regulated and mandated you have to tell
us what the five-point plan is on each
of these things and if it's not good
enough we're gonna come back to you and
ask you again
um that's a world where facebook now has
an incentive to instead of giving ten
thousand people like investing ten
thousand engineers to make the metaverse
we have ten thousand engineers to make
us safer
and that's the world we need we need to
give the power to the regulator
be able to do that because at the moment
the bill as i understand it doesn't oh
okay
uh i i believe that if facebook
doesn't have standards for those risk
assessments they will give you a bad
risk assessment because facebook is
established over and over again when
asked for information they mislead the
public
um they need to be qualified i don't
have any expectation that they'll give
you a good risk assessment unless you
articulate what a good one looks like
and you have to be able to mandate that
they give solutions
because on a lot of these problems
facebook has not thought very hard about
how to solve them or because there's no
incentive forcing them away from
shareholder interests
when they have to make those little
sacrifices like one percent growth here
or one percent growth there they choose
growth over safety
so just leading on from that just a very
quick general question as things stand
at the moment
do you think
that um this bill is keeping mark
zuckerberg awake at night
um i think i i am incredibly excited and
and proud of the uk for taking such a a
world-leading stance with regard to
thinking about regulating social
platforms
um
the global south doesn't currently does
not have the resources to stand up and
save their own lives like they they are
excluded from these discussions
and the uk has a tradition of
leading policy in ways that are followed
around the world
and i i can't imagine mark isn't paying
attention to what you're doing
because
this is a critical moment for the uk to
stand up and make sure that these
platforms are in the public good and are
designed for safety
you probably need to do a little more in
this bill to make sure that that's the
case
i have faith in you guys
you very much
you presented a very compelling argument
there on the way regulations should work
do you not think it's
let's say disingenuous of the of
companies like facebook to say we
welcome regulation we actually actively
want parliaments around the world to
regulate nick clegg was critical of
congress for not not regulating and yet
the company does none of the things that
you said it should do and doesn't share
any of that information with the
oversight board in theory created to to
have oversight of what it does
i think it's important to understand
that companies work within the
incentives and the context they're given
i think today facebook is scared that if
they
freely disclosed information i wasn't
requested by a regulator
then they might get a shareholder
lawsuit
right i think they're really scared
about doing the right thing because like
if they slow down in the united states
because they're a private company
they have a fiduciary duty to maximize
shareholder value
and so when they're given these little
choices between you know five percent
more misinformation or ten percent more
misinformation and one percent
of sessions they choose sessions and
growth over and over again and i think
there there there's actually an
opportunity i think to make the lives of
facebook employees better like rank and
file employees better by giving
appropriate uh goal posts for like what
what is a safe place because right now i
think there's a lot of people inside the
company that are uncomfortable about the
decisions that they are being forced to
make within the incentives that exist
and that creating different incentives
through regulation gives more freedom to
be able to do things that they might be
aligned with their hearts
going back to the oversight board they
yeah they don't have access to data i
mean so much your argument is about data
drives engagement drives trying to have
revenue and that's what the business is
all about and the oversight ball can't
see that i mean even when they ask for
it they told they can't have it and to
me that doesn't look like a company that
wants to be regulated
um again i think it's one of these
things where facebook i think i you know
like i said before i can't see into
men's hearts i can't see on motivations
i think but knowing what i know um uh
like you know i haven't i've i'm an odd
nerd and that i have an mba um given
what the laws are in the united states
they have to act on the shareholders
interest or they have to be able to
justify doing something else and i think
here a lot of the long-term benefits are
harder to prove right like i think if
you make facebook safer and more
pleasant it'll be a more profitable
company 10 years from now because the
toxic version of facebook is slowly
losing users
um but at the same time the actions in
the short term are easy to prove
and i think they worry that if they do
the right thing they might get a
shareholder lossy i just don't know
thank you chair and thank you francis so
much for being here it's truly
appreciated
and everything you've done to get
yourself here as well so over the last
year um look what will it take for mark
zuckerberg and the facebook executives
to actually be accountable
and do
do you think they're actually aware um
of the human cost that has been expelled
in in terms of their well i feel that
they're not accountable enough and there
has been a human price
on this
um i think it is very easy for humans to
focus on the positive over the negative
and i think it's important to remember
that facebook is a product that was
built by harvard students for other
harvard students
right like when a facebook employee
looks at their newsfeed it is likely
they see a safe pleasant place where
pleasant people discuss things together
their immediate visceral perception of
what the product is and what's happening
in a place like ethiopia they're
completely foreign worlds and i think
there's a real um
challenge of incentives where i don't
know if all the information that's
really necessary gets very high up in
the company where people where the good
news trickles up but not necessarily the
bad news and so i think it's a thing
where executives see all the good
they're generating and then they can
write off the bad as the cost of all
that good
i'm guessing now having probably watched
from afar what's been going on here in
in westminster that they probably are
very much aware of what has been going
on i really truly hope that they are
bearing in mind all the evidence
sessions that we've had and people
coming here with with just
stories that are just quite unbelievable
and you know loss of life as well
um so has it ever been a message to your
knowledge internally or privately that
they have got it wrong
there are many employees internally like
i think the the the key thing that
you'll see over and over again on the
reporting on these issues is that
countless employees said we have lots of
solutions we have lots of solutions that
don't involve picking good and bad ideas
it's not about censorship it's about the
design of the platform it's about how
fast it is how growth optimized it is
we could have a safer platform and it
could work for everyone in the world but
it'll cost little bits of growth
and i i think there's a real problem of
that
those voices don't get amplified
internally because
they're they're making the company grow
a little slower and it's a company that
that lionizes growth
and what is your view perhaps on
criminal sanctions
for online harm content do you believe
that there's a
root for criminal sanctions
um
my my philosophy on criminal sanctions
for executives is that they act like
gasoline on a law right so like like if
whatever the terms are the conditions of
a law if you if you have really strong
confidence that you've picked the right
thing they will amplify those
consequences but the same can be true of
if there are flaws in the law and so
it's hard for me to articulate with
where the law stands today whether or
not i would support criminal sanctions
but i i think there that is a real thing
that it makes executives take
consequences more seriously and so you
know it depends on where the law ends in
the in the end okay thank you um just
quick one now and you mentioned earlier
that it's easier to promote hate and
anger and i know you you touched on this
earlier and had that conversation quick
question um is the promotion of hate and
anger
is it by accident or is it by design
facebook has repeatedly said we have not
set out to design a system that promotes
anger divisive hateful content they said
we never did that we never set out to do
that but there's a huge difference
between what you set out to do which was
uh prioritize content based on its
likelihood to elicit engagement
and the consequences of that and so i i
don't think
they set out to accomplish these things
but they have been negligent in not
responding to the data as it is produced
and there is a large number of data
scientists internally who have been
raising these issues for years
and the solutions that facebook has
implemented which is in countries where
it has civic classifiers which is not
very many countries in the world very
very many languages in the world
they are removing some of the most
dangerous terms from engagement based
ranking but that ignores the fact that
the most vulnerable fragile places in
the world are linguistically diverse
like ethiopia has 100 million people and
they speak six languages facebook only
supports two supports too and it's only
a few integrity systems
and so there's this real thing of um
you know if we believe in linguistic
diversity the current design of the
platform is dangerous
just one quick one so check
online harm has been out there for some
time we're all aware of it it's very
much in in the public domain as i
touched on briefly before
why aren't the tech companies doing
anything about it why don't they just
get on why are they having to wait for
this bill to come through to make the
most obvious changes um to um what is
basically
proliferating online harm
and creating as i say
there's human loss to this why aren't
they doing something now about it
um
i think as we look at the harms of
facebook
we need to think about these things as
system problems like the idea that these
systems are designed products these are
intentional choices and that is often
difficult to see the forest for the
trees the facebook is a system of
incentives it's full of good kind
conscientious people who are working
with bad incentives
and there is a lack of incentives inside
the company to raise issues about flaws
in the system and there's lots of
rewards for amplifying and making things
grow more
and so i think there is a big challenge
of facebook's management philosophy is
that they can just pick good metrics and
let people run free
and so they have found themselves in a
trap where in a world like that how do
you propose changing the metric right
it's very very hard because a thousand
people might have directed their labor
for six months trying to move that
metric
and changing the metric will disrupt all
of that work and so i don't think
anyone's intentional i don't think they
set out to go down this path but they're
kind of trapped in it and that's why we
need regulation mandatory regulation
mandatory actions to help pull them away
from that spiral that they're caught in
thank you thank you debbie abrahams
thank you and again i reiterate all my
colleagues
thanks to you for for coming over and
giving evidence to us
i just wanted to um ask you in relation
to an interview you gave recently you
you said
facebook consistently resolved conflicts
in favor of its own profits
i wondered if you and you have speckled
the testimony that you've given
so far with these but i wonder if you
could pick two or three that you think
are really high like this at this point
um i think overall their strategy of
engagement based ranking is safe
once you have ai i think that is like
the the flagship one of showing how um
facebook has non-content-based tools
they could use to keep the platform safe
but each one of those for example um
limiting reshare chains so i said like
two hops
you know that's gonna carve off maybe
one percent of growth right uh requiring
something to click on a link before you
re-share it this is something twitter's
done twitter accepted the cost of that
change but facebook wasn't willing to
um lots of things around language
coverage
right facebook could be doing much much
more
rigorous safety systems for the
languages that they support and they
could be doing a better job of saying
we've already identified what we believe
are the most at-risk countries in the
world
but we're not giving them equal
treatment we're not giving them even uh
we're not even out of the risk zone with
them
and and i think that pattern of behavior
of being unwilling to invest in safety
is the problem okay
so
looking specifically at the events um in
washington on the 6th of january
and there's been a lot of talk about
facebook facebook's involvement um in
that
i think it's all in the moment it's it's
being
uh you that evidence is being looked at
in terms of um
depositions um
so
do is that would that be an example
would somebody have highlighted this as
a as a particular concern
taken it to the executive site i'm
absolutely horrified about what you say
about the lack of risk assessment and
risk management in the organization i
think it's a a
gross dereliction of of of
responsibility but would that have been
one example of where
facebook was aware
of of the potential harm that this could
create um
that it that was created and that they
chose
not to do anything about it
what is particularly um
problematic to me is that um
facebook
looked at its own product for the before
the us 2020 election and identified a
large number of settings so these are
things as subtle as like um
you know should we should we amplify
live videos 600 times or 60 times right
because they went live video on the top
of your feed um you know they came in
and said that setting is great for
promoting live video for making that
product grow um having impact for that
product um but it is dangerous because
like it was used on january 6 it was
used actually for coordinating the the
rioters right um facebook looked at
those risks along those you know maybe
20 interventions
and said we need to have these in place
for the election
facebook has said the reason they turned
them off was they don't you know
censorship is a delicate issue and i
find this like
this is so misleading most of those
interventions have nothing to do with
content they have questions like for
example promoting live videos 600 times
versus 60 times have you censored
someone i don't think so
um but
but so facebook is characterized they
turn those off because they don't
believe in censorship
um
on the day of january 6th
most of those interventions were still
off at 5 00 pm eastern time
right
and that's shocking because like they
could have turned them on
seven days before and so either they're
not paying enough attention for the
amount of power they have
or they are not responsive when they
when they see those things i don't know
what the what the root cause of that is
but all i know is that's an unacceptable
way to treat a system that is as
powerful and and as um delicate as this
your colleague former colleague sophie
zhang was giving evidence to the
committee last week and she made the
point that we have freedom of expression
freedom of information we don't have
freedom of amplification is that
something you'd agree with
and in terms of the censorship the the
current the current philosophy inside of
the company
is almost like
um
they refuse to acknowledge
that the power that they have like the
idea that the choices they're making
um they justify them based on growth
right um
and if they came in and said we need to
do safety first we need safety by design
i think they would choose different
parameters in terms of optimizing what
how does amplification work
because i want to remind people we liked
the version of facebook that didn't have
algorithmic amplification
like we saw our friends we saw our
families it was more human scale
and and i think there is a lot of value
and a lot of joy that could come from
returning to a facebook like that
you made a very important point about
this is a a private company
they have a fiduciary responsibility to
their
shareholders and so on i do think though
that there are breaches in their terms
of condition and conditions
so is there that again that
that conflict there i think there's two
issues so one is um i think terms and
conditions saying that private companies
can define them like that's like them
grading their own homework right like
like they're defining what's bad and
then you know we know now they don't
even find most of the thing that they
say is bad they don't have any
transparency any accountability the
second question is around
you know do companies have duties
outside of to their shareholders and we
have had a principle
for a long long time that companies
cannot subsidize their profits they
cannot pay for their profits using
public expense
right like like if you go and pollute
the water and people get cancer the
public has to pay for those people right
similarly like if facebook is
sacrificing our safety because they
don't want to invest enough
and don't don't listen to them when they
say we spend 14 billion on safety that's
not the question the question is how
much do you need to pay to make it safe
do you think then one of the things that
the the bill
or the committee rather has been looking
at is in terms of a duty of care that's
uh
is that something that we should be
considering very carefully to uh to
mandate i think a duty of care is really
important right that that um we have let
facebook
like act freely for for too long and
they've demonstrated that you know i
like to say there's multiple criteria
necessary for facebook to act completely
independently the first is when they see
conflicts of interest between themself
and the public good they resolve them
aligned with the public good and the
second is they can't lie to the public
facebook in both cases has violated
those criteria and has demonstrated they
need oversight
thank you so much my final question is
and do you think
the regulator is going to be out to the
job
i think um
i am not a lawmaker and so i don't know
a ton about the design of regulatory
bodies
but i do think that things like having
risks mandatory risk assessments with a
certain level of quality is a flexible
technique
that as long as facebook is required to
articulate solutions
that that might be a good enough dynamic
where as long as there's also community
input into that risk assessment like
that might actually be a system that
could be sustainable over time because
the reality is facebook's going to keep
trying to run around the edges
and so we need to have something that
can continue over time not to play
whack-a-mole on specific pieces of
content or unlike specific incidences
thanks so much francis
thank you joining us remotely darren
jones
thank you chair and just i'm following
on from the discussion i have
some of the provisions in this bill
might be operationalized um in the
day-to-day
facebook
firstly there's a distinction in the
bill between illegal content such as
terrorism
and legal but harmful
and the question about how you define
what is harmful is based on the idea
that a company like facebook would
reasonably foresee that something was
causing harm and we've seen through some
of the leaks over the last few weeks
that facebook undertakes research
internally but maybe doesn't publish
that or share the information with
external researchers if facebook just
stopped researching potential harms and
claimed they had no reasonable foresight
of new harms and would they just be able
to get around the risk assessment in
your view
i am extremely worried about facebook
ceasing to do important research and it
is a great illustration of how dangerous
it is to have a company as powerful as
facebook where the only one who gets to
ask questions of facebook is facebook
like we probably need something like a
postdoc program where public public
interest people are embedded in the
company for a couple of years and they
can ask questions they can work on real
problems they can learn about these
systems and then go out and seed
academia and train the next generation
of of integrity workers
um i think there are uh big questions
around um so legal but harmful content
is is dangerous right like for example
misinformation that actually leads to
people losing their lives there's like
large social societal harmful
consequences of this
i'm also concerned that um if you don't
cover legal but harmful content you will
have a much much smaller impact of this
bill and especially on impacts to
children for example a lot of the
content that we're talking about here is
would be legal but harmful legal but
harmful content
thank you and i know that in your
answers today you've said that there's
not enough internal work to understand
harms and that data should be shared
with external academics and regulators
and i agree with you on those points my
second question is um
say the company found some new type of
harmful content a new trend or some type
of content that was
leading to physical or mental harm to
individuals we talked today about how
complex the facebook world is whether
it's about content promotion or groups
or messaging
how would you go about auditing and
assessing
how this harm is being shared within the
facebook environment it sounds like a
very big job to me how would you
actually go about doing it
so one of the reasons why i'm such a big
advocate of like having a fire hose so
that's like picking some standard where
you're like if more than x thousands of
people see this content it's not really
private
um is that you can include metadata
about each piece of content for example
did it come via a group what group
um
how where where on average and someone's
feed to this content show up uh and
which groups are most exposed to it like
imagine if we could tell oh facebook is
actually distributing a lot of self-harm
content to children right there's
various metadata we could be releasing
and i think there is a really
interesting opportunity that once more
data is accessible outside of the
company
i think a cottage industry will will
spring up amongst academics amongst
independent researchers like if i had
access to this data i would start a
youtube channel and i would just teach
people about it right
um i can tell jokes for 15 minutes
but
the
um i think there's opportunities where
we will develop the muscle
of oversight but we will only develop
the muscle of oversight if we have at
least a people to look into facebook
so facebook would say to us for example
well if there's a unique and new type of
harm that's been created a new trend
that's been appearing in private groups
and has maybe been shared a little bit
because of the amount of content on the
platform it's really difficult for us to
find it and assess that properly you're
saying that that's not true and they
have the capabilities to do that
so
as i said earlier i think it's really
important for facebook to have to
publish which integrity systems exist
right like what what content can they
find because we should be able to um
have the public
surface like hey we believe there's this
harm here and be like oh interesting you
don't actually look for that harm so the
example i i heard was around um
uh self-inflicted harm content um and
kids and like our some kids being
overexposed and facebook said we don't
track that content or we don't track
that
um
we don't have a mechanism today
to force facebook to answer those
questions and we need to have something
that would be mandatory where we could
say you need to be tracking this harm
um
i'm sorry i forgot your question my
abilities
i think you've broadly answered it i
just wanted you to answer the to the
question that they have the capacity to
to two years my last two questions are
more about corporate governance of the
business and
i'm interested to know from your
experience how the different teams
within the business operate so a
question i've asked previously in this
committee is
you know the programmers who might be
down the end of the corridor who are
coding all of these algorithms will know
a certain amount of information the
product teams that build products we'll
know a bit about what the programmers
have done but probably not the whole
thing and how it works properly and then
the compliance and pr team will just
have to receive answers probably from
the product team in order to produce
this risk assessment that they then
present to
our regulator and my concern is that the
real truth about what's happening is
with the programmers that it may not get
through unless we force it
to in that audit submission to our
regulator
am i wrong in those assumptions do those
teams work together well in
understanding what they all do and how
it links together
i think it's really important to to know
that there are conflicts of interests
between those teams right so one of
things that's been raised is the fact
that at twitter uh the team that is
responsible for writing policy on what
is harmful
reports separately to the ceo than the
team that is responsible for external
relations with governmental officials
and on facebook those two teams report
to the same person so the person who is
responsible for keeping politicians
happy is the same person that gets to
define what is harmful or not harmful
content
um i think there is a real problem
around um
the left hand doesn't speak to the right
hand of facebook right it's like the
example i gave earlier of uh on one hand
someone on integrity is saying
problematic use addiction
is like one of the signs of it is you
you come back a lot of times a day and
then someone on the growth team is
saying how did you notice like we get
you to come back a bunch of times a day
you still use the product in three
months right there it's just like
there's a world that's too flat where no
one is really responsible like antonia
frazier said um in her senate testimony
like when she was pressed on instagram
kids and various decisions she she
couldn't articulate who was responsible
and that is a real challenge at facebook
that there is not any system or
responsibility or governance
and so you end up in situations like
that where you have one team you know
not probably unknowingly pushing
behaviors that cause more more addiction
so it may be that we need to look at
forcing a type of uh risk committee like
an audit committee in a business where
the relevant people are coming together
to at least it might be good to include
in the risk assessments saying what are
your organizational risk assessments not
just your product risk assessments
because the organizational choices of
facebook are are introducing systematic
risk systemic risk
and my very last question
is this is a piece of law
here in the uk has some international
reach but it's obviously uk law we've
heard evidence before that
employees of different technology
companies here in london um
will want to be helpful and give certain
answers but actually the decisions are
really made in california do you think
there's a risk
the way in which power is structured in
california means that the uk based teams
trying to combine with the law here may
not be able to do what they need to do
um
facebook today
is full of kind conscientious people who
work in a system of incentives that
unfortunately leads to bad results
results that are harmful to society um
there is definitely a center of mass
that exists in mellow park
there is definitely
a greater priority on moving growth
metrics than safety metrics
and you may have safety teams located in
london or elsewhere in the world who
their actions will be greatly hindered
or even rolled back on behalf of growth
a real problem again when we're talking
about this idea of the right hand in the
left hand there are reports inside of
facebook that talk about the idea that
an integrity team might spend months
pushing out a fix that lowers
misinformation 10 10
but because the ai is so poorly
understood
people will add in little factors that
will basically recreate whatever the the
term was that was fixed and reintroduced
right and so it it over and over if the
incentives are bad you will get bad
behavior
understood thank you these are my
questions jay thanks
thank you will stevenson
uh thank you very much
my thanks to everybody else for the
incredible picture you've painted i mean
i think we've mentioned that we
recognize the problem you face by doing
what you've done but it is fantastic to
be able to get a real
sense of what's happening inside the
company and i just wanted to pick up on
what was
being said just a few minutes ago
it's almost like 1984 some of your
descriptions and
you when you talked about the names
given to the
company all parts of the organization
that are actually supposed to be doing
the opposite of what the name seems to
imply that does
that raises an issue
i just wanted to ask about the culture
you ended up by saying there were lots
of people in facebook who
got what you're saying
but you also said that the promotion
structure possibly pointed in a
different direction and therefore these
people didn't necessarily get up to the
positions of power that you might expect
now organizations have a culture of
their own so
in a sense my question is really about
culture do you think that
there is a possibility that
with a regulated structure of the type
we're talking about
being
being seen as the way forward in the in
the way the world deals with these huge
companies that we've never had to deal
with before
there are sufficient people of good
heart and good
sense in the company to rescue it or do
you feel that somehow the the the
duality that you're talking about the
left hand of the right hand has got so
bad that it will it will never ever
recover itself it has to be done by an
external agency it's a very complicated
question but it comes back to culture
really do you think there's a way in
which it might happen
i think unless the incentives change the
the incentives under which facebook
change ex
until the incentives the facebook
operates under changes we will not see
changes from facebook and so i think
it's this question of facebook is full
of kind conscientious good people
but the systems reward growth and the
wall street journal has reported um on
how um people have advanced inside the
company and disproportionately the
people who are the managers and leaders
of the integrity teams these safety
teams come originally from the growth of
works
like the path to management in integrity
and safety is via growth and that seems
deeply problematic it was a bit doomed
i think there is a need to
provide an external weight and a pull
to move it away from just being
optimized on short-termism and immediate
shareholder profitability and more
towards the public good which i think
actually is going to lead to a more
profitable successful company 10 years
down the road
you may not be able to answer this in a
sense
an easy question to answer but
inside the company the things that
you've been saying
are
being said
at the water fountain and you know in
the corridors so so i think you've said
that that you know people do talk about
these things
what is it that stops it getting getting
picked up as an official policy is is
there actually a
in a gatekeeper on this on behalf of the
growth group which just simply says fine
they've had enough time talking that
move on
um
i don't think there is an explicit
gatekeeper right it's not like a thing
of like there are things we cannot say
um but i think there is a real bias of
that you know experiments are taken to
review
and the costs and the benefits are
assessed and facebook has characterized
some of the things that i've talked
about as in terms of we're we're against
censorship and the things that i'm
talking about are not content-based like
i am not like here to advocate for more
censorship i'm about saying how do we
make the platform more human scale how
do we how do we move back to things like
chronological ranking
um have finding ways to move towards
solutions that work for all languages
but in order to do that we have to
accept the cost of little bits of growth
being lost and i i love the radical idea
of like what if facebook wasn't
profitable for one year are they this
giant pile of cash what for one year
they had to focus on making it safe what
would happen what kind of infrastructure
would get built um and i think there's a
real thing of that until incentives
change facebook will not change
i'll leave it there
someone's asking about that because
if i was a charity that worked say with
um
teenage girls who'd self-harmed and i
said i've got this organization i've got
the profiles the facebook and instagram
profiles of lots of people that have
interacted with our charity what i want
to do is i want to reach out on facebook
and instagram to so other people are
like those people and see if we can help
them before before they do themselves
too much heart would be wonderful yeah
but i could do that i could go to
facebook and say
could i use look like the lookalike
audience is ad tool
in order to reach those people and they
would happily sell that to me to do it
and they have the data to find the
closest possible data matches to young
people who are self-abusing
for the purpose of selling advertising
it couldn't be couldn't be simpler the
way the platform's designed but yet if
you ask the same question around saying
why don't you do more to reach out and
help people that are actually in danger
of self-harming why don't you stop it
when you practically reach out and not
only do they not do that they will sell
you an ad to do it they won't do it
themselves but actually worse than that
they're continually feeding those self
saying vulnerable people with content
that's likely to make them even more
vulnerable yeah and i don't see how that
is as a company that is
good kind and conscientious
there's a difference between systems and
i always come back to this question of
what are the incentives and what what
what system do these incentives create
and i can only tell you what i saw at
facebook which is i saw kind
conscientious people but they were
limited by the actions that of the
system they worked under and that's part
of why regulation is so important and
the example you give of one
amplification of interests so facebook
has run the experiment where they get
exposed to very centrist interests like
healthy recipes
and just by following the
recommendations on on instagram they are
led to anorexia content very fast within
a week right just by following the
recommendations because extreme
polarizing content
is the ones that get rewarded by
engagement based ranking
um
i have never heard described what you
just described i.e using the lookalike
tools that exist today if you want to
target ads today you can take an
audience like maybe people who bought
your product previously and find a
look-alike audience it's very profitable
advertisers love this tool i've never
thought about it about using it to to
reach out critical content to people who
might be in danger right now the number
of people who see the current self-harm
tools
so this is like facebook loves to brag
about how they built tools to protect
kids or like protect people who might
have eating disorders those tools
trigger on the order of hundreds of
times a day
single like hundreds hundreds of
thousands hundreds globally um and so i
think unquestionably facebook should
have to do things like that
um and have partnerships with with
people who can help connect them to
vulnerable populations because you're
right they have the tools and they just
haven't done it
when you were working in the civic
integrity team when the civic civic
integrity team existed could you have
made a request like that to facebook so
we've identified some accounts here and
some people we think are very
problematic and actually we'd like to
use some of the ad tools to try and
identify more people like that would
would would that have been a
conversation you could have had
i've had that conversation um
there is a concept known as
defensibility inside the company where
um they are very careful
about any action which they believe is
not defensible
and things that are statistically likely
but are not proven to be bad they are
very hesitant to do it's like let's
imagine you found some terrorists and
you were looking for other people who
are at risk of being recruited for
terrorism or cartels this happens in
mexico the platforms are used to recruit
young people into cartels
you can imagine using a technique like
that to to help people were at risk of
being radicalized
um facebook would have come back and
said there's no guarantee that those
people are at risk like we shouldn't
label them in a negative way because we
that wouldn't be defensible
um and so i think there's things where
um
[Music]
coming in and changing the incentives
right like making them articulate risks
and making them articulate how they'll
fix those risks i think pretty rapidly
they would shift their philosophies on
how to approach problems and they'd be
more willing to act but it would be
defensible to sell a terrorist guns
using an ad tool
their their known interest in that
subject would be defensible to sell it
for advertising but not defensible to
reach out for civic integrity i i'm not
sure if facebook allows gun sales i do
know that they have that sorry example
yeah yeah what i'm saying is what i'm
saying is this is scenario you could
feed someone's addiction by advertising
them you can't use the same technology
to reach out and help them yes it's
actually worse than that like um when i
in my senate testimony um one of the
senators showed this example of an ad
that was targeted at children
where in the background the ad was an
image of a bunch of people like a bunch
of pills and tablets very clearly a pile
of drugs
and said something like want to have
your best skittles party this weekend
reach out or something and a skittles
party apparently is a youth code for a
drug party and like that ad got approved
by facebook and so there is a real thing
where facebook says they have policies
for things like they might have a policy
stand we don't sell guns but i bet
there's tons of ads on the platform that
are selling guns well they have a
policies that i hate speech and there's
quite a lot oh there's tons of hate
speech yeah but but it sounds like what
you've got is one part of the business
that with razor-like focus more than has
probably ever been created in in the
human existence can target people's
addictions through advertising and yet
the other part of the business is there
to try and keep people safe is largely
feeling around in the dark
there is a great asymmetry in resources
that are invested to grow the company
versus to keep it safe
it's not just there's no what you said
it's not
there's not just an asymmetry it's you
kind of you can't even request you can't
even go to the people with all the data
and all the information and say could we
use some of your tools to help us do our
job because they would say it's not
defensible to do that i i
never saw the usage of a strategy like
that but it seems like a logical thing
to do like facebook should be using all
the tools in its power to fight these
problems and it's not doing that today i
think i think a lot of people
extrapolate for that was if it weren't
if it if the senior management team
really wanted to do it it would have it
would have been done
but for some reason it appears that they
don't
i think there are cultural issues and
there's definitely issues at the highest
levels of leadership where they are not
prioritizing safety sufficiently and
it's not enough to say look we invested
14 billion dollars we need to come back
and say no
you might have to spend twice that to
have a safe platform the important part
is it should be designed to be safe
not we should have to defend we should
have to plead with you to be safe
even kidroom
um
francis i was really struck earlier when
you said they know more about abuse but
they it's a failure of willingness to
act i think it was the phrase
and it brought to my mind a
particular case
um of judy and andy thomas whose
daughter committed suicide and struggled
for the last year to get anything beyond
an automated response for their request
uh to have uh francis
um
access to her account
um
i made a small intervention they did
eventually get a
an answer but that answer really
basically said no you can't and and i
have to be clear just for legal things
it didn't say no you can't it was a very
complicated answer complicated legal
answer
but what it was saying is that they had
to protect
the privacy of third parties on
france's account
so i really
wanted to just uh
um sorry i thought of francis it was
frankie but
um i just really wanted you to say
whether you think
that
privacy defense
is okay in this
setting or whether actually you know the
sort of report and complaint piece is
another thing we really need to look at
because that seems pretty horrendous to
give grieving parents some sort of
completion
i from from what you describe i think
their their argument is that on the
i think there's a really interesting
distinction around
private versus public content
like they could have come in and said at
least for the public content that she
viewed like the the worldwide available
content we can show you that content
like i think they probably should have
come in and done that
um
i wouldn't be surprised if they no
longer had the data like they'd delete
the data after like 90 days
and so unless she was like a terrorist
and they were tracking her which i
assume she wasn't um and they would have
they would have lost all that history
within 90 days of her passing
and that is a recurrent thing that
facebook does is that they know that
whatever their sins are it will recede
into the fog of time within 90 days
the idea of user privacy being a reason
for
not giving a parent of a deceased child
access to what they were seeing i'm just
interested in that more thematic
um i i think there is an unwillingness
at facebook to acknowledge that they are
responsible to anyone
right they they don't disclose data like
there's lots of ways to disclose data in
a privacy conscious way
you just have to want to do it and
facebook has shown not over and over
again not just that you don't want to
release that data but even when they do
release that data they often mislead
people and and lie in its construction
like they did this with researchers a
couple months ago they literally
released misinformation
using assumptions that they did not
disclose the researchers that were
misleading in the case of those grieving
parents um you know i'm sure that
facebook has not thought holistically
about the experience of parents that
have had traumas on the platform
right because i'm sure that her parents
aren't the only ones that have suffered
that way
and i think it it's cruel of facebook to
not think about you know how do they how
do they even take minor responsibility
after an event like that
okay
a lot of colleagues have uh talked to
you about children and that's a
particular interest of mine the one
thing that hasn't come up this afternoon
is age assurance and specifically
privacy preserving age assurance and
this is something that i'm very worried
about that age assurance used badly
could drive
more surveillance could drive more
resistance to regulation and we need
rules of the road and i'm just
interested to know your perspective on
that
i
i think there is it's kind of a two-fold
situation so on one side
there are many algorithmic techniques
facebook could be using to keep children
off the platform that are not involving
asking for ids or other forms of
information disclosure
facebook currently does not disclose
what what they do and so we can't as a
society step in and say you actually
have a much larger tool chest you could
be drawing from and it also means we
don't understand what the privacy
violations are that are happening today
we have no idea what they're doing um
the second thing is that we could be
we could be grading facebook's homework
instead of relying on them grading their
homework which is that facebook has
systems for estimating the age of any
user
and within a year or two of them turning
13 like enough of their actual age mates
have now joined that they can estimate
accurately what the real age of that
person is and facebook should have to
publish both that protocol of how they
do that and publish the results going
back a couple years of saying one two
three four years ago
how many 10 year olds were on the
platform how many 12 year olds were on
the platform because they know this data
today
and they are not disclosing to the
public and that would be a forcing
function to make them do better
detection of young people on the
platform
okay i have been ticking off of a list
while you've been speaking this
afternoon and you know mandatory risk
assessments and mitigation measures
mandatory routes of transparency
um
mandatory safety by design moderation
uh with humans in the loop i think you
said um
algorithmic design
and
application of their own policies
right will that
set of things in the regulator's hand in
our bill that we are looking at
would all of that keep children safe
would it save lives would it stop abuse
would it be enough
i think it would unquestionably be a
much much safer platform if facebook had
to take the time to articulate its risks
and i think this is the second part they
can't just articulate their risks they
have to articulate their path to solve
those risks it has to be mandated and
they can't like have like do a half
solution they need to give you a high
quality answer
um because remember like we would never
accept a car company that had you know
five times the car accidents coming out
and saying
you know we're really sorry but breaks
are so hard
right we're going to get better we would
never accept that answer but we hear
that from facebook over and over again
and i think between having more
transparency mandatory transparency
privacy conscious um
and having a process of that
conversation around what are the
problems and what are the solutions that
is a path that should be resilient in
moving us forward to a safer facebook or
any social media thank you
tim clement jones
that's fine um in that case i think jim
and i had a question he wanted to
bring back
yeah thank you um
we've
been informed that your comments the
media on
uh
end-to-end subscription um have been
misrepresented um
you know i'm interested whether it's
something that we should be concerned on
this
committee in in terms of uh whether
there's a regulatory risk and certainly
there are security risks that um some
parts of government are concerned about
and then to end uh
encryption but um i'd like to give you
the opportunity first to clarify what
your position is and if there's any
comment that you've got for us on
on whether we should be concerned about
that area then i'll be grateful to you
um i want to be very very clear i was uh
mischaracterized in the telegraph
yesterday on my opinions around and
encryption so ending encryption is where
you encrypted information on a device
you send it over the internet and it's
decrypted on another device
um
i am a strong supporter of access to
open source
end-to-end encryption software part of
why i'm such an advocate for open source
software in this case is that if you are
an activist if you're someone who has a
sensitive need a journalist or a
whistleblower my primary form of social
software is an open source antenna
encryption chat platform
but part of why that open source part is
so important is you can see the code
anyone can go and look at it and for the
top open source end-to-end encryption
platforms those are some of the only
ways you're allowed to do chat and say
the defense department in the united
states
facebook's plan for undead encryption i
think is is concerning because we have
no idea what they're going to do we
don't know what it means like we don't
know people's privacy is actually
protected
it's super nuanced we don't uh and it's
also a different context right so on the
open source uh
antenna encryption product that i like
to use um there is no directory where
you can find uh 14 year olds right there
is no directory where you can go and
find the you know uyghur community in
bangkok on facebook it is trivially easy
to access vulnerable populations and
there are nation state actors that are
doing this and so i want to be clear
it's i am not against and encryption in
messenger but i do believe the public
has a right to know what does that even
mean are they really going to produce
end-to-end encryption because if they
say they're doing end-to-end encryption
and they don't really do that people's
lives are in danger
and i personally don't trust facebook
currently to tell the truth and i'm
scared that they are waving their hands
at a situation where they're concerned
about various issues and they just don't
want to
see the dangers anymore i'm concerned
about them misconstruing
the product that they build and they
need regulatory oversight for that
that's my position on end encryption
so just to be really clear
uh there's a really important use case
for end-to-end uh encryption and
messaging but if you ended up with an
integration of some of the other things
that you can do on facebook with
end-to-end encryption then you can
create quite a dangerous place for
certain vulnerable groups i think
there's two sides so one uncare like
like i want to be super clear i support
access to end down encryption and i use
open source and encryption every day
right my social support network is
currently on an open source and an
encryption service
but i am concerned on one side that the
the constellation of factors related to
facebook um makes it makes it even more
necessary for public oversight of how we
do end-to-end encryption there that's
things like access to the directory
those amplification settings but the
second one is just about security
if people think they're using an
end-to-end encryption product and
facebook's interpretation of that is
different than what say an open source
product would do because an open source
product we can all look at it and make
sure what it says on the label is in the
can
but if facebook claims they've built an
end to encryption thing and there's
really vulnerabilities people's lives
are on the line and that's what i'm
concerned about we need public oversight
of anything facebook does around ending
encryption because they are they are
making people feel safe when they might
be in danger
thank you very much um david
thank you so much just a quick follow-up
are you aware of any uh facebook
analysis
uh in relation to the human cost of
misinformation
so for example co
covert as a hoax or
anti-vax misinformation
have they done anything have they
actually tried to quantify that both in
terms of
illness uh deaths the actual um
human costs um facebook has done many
studies looking at the um
the the
the misinformation burden is not shared
evenly
right so you have things like the most
exposed people to misinformation are
like recently widowed recently divorced
moved to a new city
and when you put people into these
rabbit holes when you when you pull
people in from from mainstream beliefs
into extreme beliefs
it cuts them off from their communities
because if i begin to believe in flat
earth things and i have friends that are
flat earthers it makes it hard for me to
reintegrate into my family in the united
states the metaphor we often use is the
idea of is thanksgiving dinner ruined
right like did your relative go and
consume too much misinformation on
facebook and now that's become
thanksgiving dinner and i think when we
look at the social costs when we look at
the health cost i'll give you an example
facebook under enforces on comments
right they because comments are so much
shorter they're really hard for the ai
to figure out
um right now
uh groups like unicef have really
struggled even with the free ad credits
the facebook has given them because they
will promote positive information about
the vaccine or about ways to carry
yourself with covid and they'll get
piled on in the comments
and so facebook's own documents talk
about unicef saying how much more impact
would those ad dollars have had if they
hadn't been
buried in toxic content
thank you so much thank you
thank you um dean russell
thank you chair um i just wanted to
build on a comment you made earlier if
that's okay you mentioned about this
idea of skills parties so i think if i'd
heard it right and it occurred to me
actually
how do the platforms evolve in terms of
the language obviously we've talked
about different types of languages but
thinking of english within english
there's huge differences between
american english and english english you
can call it that british english um but
also the slang that's used and when you
were mentioning that it occurred to me a
few weeks ago i had someone on facebook
on that they'd met me in a pub
previously and they wish they'd given me
a glasgow hug which it turns out it's
worse than a glasgow kiss that actually
means to stab me um within the time of
somebody of that being reported i only
found out about this afterwards it was
reported initially to facebook
they said it didn't break any of their
rules i believe someone else then repea
reported it and a few others and it
eventually got took down either by the
the the the page it was on or by
facebook in that time someone else had
put on it they'd met me during an
election
campaign and they wish they'd give me a
glasgow hug as well so in other words
two people wanting to stab me publicly
uh on the platform now when that was
reported and clarified to facebook that
a glasgow herg meant to stab me separate
from a glasgow kiss which i think is a
headbutt um which is just
awful um i wonder do you know within
facebook would it learn from that would
it know the next time somebody says they
want to give someone a glasgow hug that
they mean to stab them or would that
just be lost into the ether
i think it is
likely that they would get lost into the
ether right that the the process
facebook is very cautious
about how they evolve lists around
things like hate speech or threats and
um
it is
i did not see a great deal of
regionalization
which is what is necessary to do
content-based interventions i did not
see them investing in a very high level
of regionalization that would be
necessary to do that effectively and and
i think there's interesting design
questions where like if we as a
community that means
government academics
independent researchers came together
and said let's think about how facebook
could actually gather enough structured
data to be able to get that case right
or like in the case of you know the
insult for the other member um like uh
how do you do that right and and i think
if they took a strategy that was closer
to what google has done historically
they would likely have a substantially
safer product which is google was
committed to be available in i think 5
000 languages right like how do you make
google uh interfaces how do you make the
help content available in basically all
the major languages in the world and the
way they did that was they invested in a
community program where they said we
need the help of the community to make
this accessible
and if facebook invested the time and
effort and the collaborations with
academia or with other researchers but
the government to figure out
collaborative strategies for producing
the structured data i think we'd have a
way safer facebook i don't support their
current integrity strategies i think
content-based solutions are not great
but they could be so much better than
they are today
um so let's make the platform safer and
if you want to continue to use ai let's
figure out how to actually do it in a
way that protects you from scottish
english not just from american english
right thank you and and just a
further question on that because that
for me builds into this question of the
evolution of these platforms the
learning that they have but also future
proofing this bill against future
changes at the moment we talk a lot
about facebook and google and twitter
and all those things as being looked at
on a screen but increasingly they are
working in the realms of virtual reality
obviously there's oculus rift as well
which will increasingly enable user
generated content or engagement um do
you know whether any of the principles
that we're talking about here
around safety and reducing harm are
being discussed for those future um
innovations because my concern to be
honest is that we'll get this bill right
and then actually the world will shift
into a into a different type of use of
of platforms and actually we won't have
covered the bases properly
i'm actually a little excited about
augmented reality because often
augmented reality attempts to recreate
interactions that we exist in physical
reality right like in this room we have
maybe 40 people total and the
interactions that we have socially are
at a human scale
most augmented reality experiences that
i've seen have been more about trying to
recreate dynamics of an individual
they're either games that you play or
they are communications with one or
maybe a handful of people and and those
systems have a very different
consequence than the hyper amplification
systems that facebook has built today
like the danger with facebook is not
individuals saying bad things
it is about the systems of amplification
that disproportionately give people
saying extreme polarizing things the
largest megaphone in the room
and so i agree with you that we have to
be careful about thinking about future
proofing but i i think the the
mechanisms that we talked about earlier
about the idea of having risk
assessments and risk assessments that
aren't just produced by the company but
need to also be the regulator gathering
from the community and saying are there
other things we should be concerned
about
right a tandem approach like that that
requires companies to articulate their
solutions i think that's a flexible
approach i think that might work for
quite a long time but it has to be
mandatory and there have to be certain
quality bars because if facebook can
phone it in i guarantee you they'll
phone it in
thank you back to you chair thanks very
much thank you thank you just a couple
of final questions from me um
the um we heard in the
evidence session we heard last week
uh i think it was um
guillaume shallow so based on his
experience at uh youtube said that um
the way algorithmic recommendation works
it's not there to give you more of what
you want it's there to discover which
rabbit hole you should be pushed into do
you think that's a fair characterization
um there's a difference between the
intended goals of a system so like
facebook has said we never intended to
make a system that amplifies extreme
polarizing content and the consequences
of a system so all recommender systems
intend to give you content that you will
enjoy because as facebook has said that
will keep you on the platform longer
but the reality is that algorithmic
systems ai systems are very complicated
and we are bad at assessing the
consequences or foreseeing what they're
going to be
but they're very attractive to use
because they keep you on the site longer
right if we went back to chronological
ranking i bet you'd view 20 less content
every day but you might enjoy it more be
more from your friends and family
um
the
uh the question on rabbit holes i don't
think they intended to have you go down
rabbit holes i don't think they intended
to force people into um these bubbles
though they have chosen choices that um
have unintended siding effects so i'll
give you an example autoplay i think
autoplay on youtube is super dangerous
right so autoplay instead of having you
choose what you want to engage with
it chooses for you and it keeps you in a
stream of flow
where it just keeps you going there's no
conscious action of continuing or
picking things or
or of whether or not to stop right
and that's where those rabbit holes come
from but the equivalent on facebook
seemed to be from what we said earlier
on that someone signs you up to a group
without your consent that's
that's focused on anti-backs uh
conspiracy theories on covet you engage
in all of the postings do you see it in
your news feed you know you were asked
for it you're now what's actually a
member of the group and probably not
just when you get more content from that
group but that's quite an interesting
deviation from stuff you've done before
and probably the whole system will give
you more of that kind of content so i
thought that's that's what i meant i
think between the system recognizing a
kind of interesting new
line of inquiry from the user and then
piling in on that with more stuff i
think that's what's so scary um there's
been some reporting on a story about um
a test user so facebook has said it
takes two to tango so nick clegg wrote a
post back in march saying don't blame us
for the extreme content you see on
facebook you chose your friends you
chose your interests it takes two to
tango
when you make a brand new account and
you follow some mainstream interests
for example fox news trump melania it
will lead you
very rapidly to q anon it will lead you
very rapidly to white genocide content
but this isn't just true on the right
it's true on the left as well these
systems lead to amplification and
division
and and i i think you're right like it's
a question of like uh
the system wants to find the content
that will make you engage more and that
is extreme polarizing content yeah i
think
to claim is neglected in that situation
that it's too tango it's almost like
you're it's your fault that you're
seeing all this up is again a massive
misrepresentation of the way that the
company actually works facebook is very
good at dancing with data they have very
good communicators and the reality is
like the business model is leading them
to dangerous and dangerous actions yeah
so if you're
if it's too tango the other part the
other party is facebook not another user
actually sort of that yes um
on on fake accounts we heard from sophie
zang last week about her work uh
identifying networks of an authentic
activity
based on your work at facebook how big a
problem do you think that is on things
like civil integrity around elections
you know i mean in some of sophie's
evidence i mean we're talking networks
of hundreds of thousands of accounts
that have been taken down and how much
problems in your area of work i'm
extremely worried about fake accounts
and i want to give you guys some context
on a taxonomy around fake accounts so
there are
bots so these things are automated
basic's reasonably good at detecting
bots like it's not perfect but it's
reasonably good then there are things
called manually driven fake accounts so
a manually driven fake account
is um for example there are cottage
industries in in certain pockets of the
world there's certain parts of pakistan
there's certain parts of of africa
there's certain pockets where people
have realized that you can pay a child a
dollar to play with an account like a 12
year old to be a fake
35 year old for a month
and during that window you will have
passed the window of scrutiny at
facebook and you will look like a real
human because you are a real human
and that account can be resold to
someone else because it is now looks
like a real human account
and those accounts um uh there are
there's at least a hundred thousand of
them among the
um there's 800 000 i believe or back
when i left so this is mark may there
were approximately 800 000 facebook
connectivity accounts so these are the
accounts where facebook is subsidizing
your internet
among those there were a hundred
thousand of these manually driven fake
accounts that were discovered by a
colleague of mine they were being used
for some of the worst offenses on the
platform
and i think there is a huge problem
around the level of investment facebook
has done in detecting these accounts and
preventing them from spreading harm on
the platform
how confident are you that the
the number of active
users on facebook is
accurate that those people are real
people
um
i i
i think there's interesting things
around uh
the general number so as we talked about
before this is about distribution of
things now on on social networks things
aren't necessarily evenly allocated so
facebook has published a number of i
believe 11 that believes 11 of its
accounts are are not people like their
duplicates
um amongst
new accounts
they believe the number is closer to 60
but that has never been disclosed in my
awareness in a public statement and so
there's this question of if investors
are interpreting the value of the
company based on a certain number of new
accounts every month and 60 of those are
not
actually new people
they're over inflating the value of
company
and i mean if that those audiences are
being sold to advertisers as a real
people and that's fortunate
if you're selling you're selling fake
selling people you've got reason to
believe probably fake you're selling as
real people to advertisers so there is a
problem known as sumas which are same
user multiple accounts
and
we had documentation
that said excuse me i found
documentation that said
for reach and frequency advertising so
let's say you're targeting a very
specific population maybe they're highly
affluent and slightly quirky individuals
and you're gonna sell them some very
specific product
facebook is amazing for these niches
because maybe there's only a hundred
thousand people in the united states
that you want to reach but you can get
all them right facebook has put in
controls called reach and frequency
advertising so you say i don't want to
reach someone more than seven times or
maybe 10 times because that 30th
impression
uh it's not very effective
and facebook's internal research says
that those systems the reach and
frequency advertising systems were not
accurate because they didn't take into
consideration these same user multiple
account effects so that is that is
definitely um facebook overcharging
people for their product
that and and that's that should be works
in the same way on instagram as well i'm
sure it does and there have been
concerns raised about in particular
young people encouraged to have multiple
duplicate accounts on on facebook is
that a concern so on instagram how do
you play accounts duplicate accounts on
instagram is that something you share
from a safety do you share that concern
from a safety point of view
um
i think that there were i i was present
for multiple conversations during my
time in civic integrity where they
discussed the idea that you know on
facebook the real names policy
and the the policies against um
uh like like uh their authenticity
policies
those are security features and then on
instagram because they didn't have that
same contract there were there were many
accounts that would have been taken down
on facebook for coordinated behavior and
other things that because they weren't
inauthentic it was harder to take them
down and so i think in the case of
teenagers
encouraging teenagers to make private
accounts so that say their parents can't
understand what's happening in their
lives i think is is really dangerous and
there should be more family-centric
integrity intervention so think about
the family as an ecosystem yeah because
as you say a young person engaging with
harmful content problem content probably
do it using a different account while
they their parents see the one that they
think
they should have
but i mean do you think the policy needs
to change do you think this system can
be made to work on instagram as it does
today
um
i don't think i know about enough about
instagram this behavior in that way to
give a good opinion okay but as a kind
of concerned citizen who worked in
i i think i i strongly believe that
facebook is not transparent enough today
and that it's difficult for us to
actually figure out the right thing to
do because we are not told accurate
information about how the system itself
works yeah and that's unacceptable i
think we'd agree with that i think
that's that's a good summation i think a
lot of what we've been talking about
this afternoon i think that concludes
the questions from the committee so we'd
just like to thank you for your evidence
and for taking the trouble to visit us
here in westminster thank you so much
for that thank you thank you thank you
very much
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
parliament live dot tv
parliament live dot tv
parliament live dot tv
parliament live dot
tv parliament live dot tv
parliament live dot tv
parliament live dot tv
parliament live dot tv
parliament live dot tv
parliament live dot tv
parliament live dot tv
live dot tv
parliament live dot tv
parliament live dot tv
parliament live dot tv
parliament live dot tv
parliament live dot tv
parliament live dot tv
parliament live dot tv
parliament live dot tv